Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlaff und das hier ist Ausgabe einundsiebzig von UKW und es ist Freitag und das heißt, es ist
Coronawickly mit mir und mit Pavel, hallo Pavel. Der.
Ne? Und das ist der dreißigste April.
Genau, es ist der dreißigste April zwanzig einundzwanzig. Noch ist nicht alles äh vorbei, aber es wird besser. Wie, das werden wir heute äh erklären, wie es hier unsere Art ist, immer,
am Freitag schauen wir auf die Entwicklung in der Coronakrise mit Schwerpunkt Deutschland. Ab und zu schauen wir auch mal woanders hin, machen wir heute auch,
aber trotzdem unser Fokus ist natürlich auf Deutschland. Ja, weiß nicht, ist irgendwas äh.
Irgendwas Besonderes passiert diese Woche eigentlich nicht, ne?
Nö, nichts wirklich spektakuläres, allerdings äh so haben wir.
So seit zwei Tagen äh eine leicht sinkende äh sieben Tage Inzidenz, die ist jetzt auf hundertdreiundsechzig,
gefallen ähm so hm in innerhalb von zwei Tagen und der aber vor allen Dingen ja seit gestern ist dann der sieben Tage R-Wert knapp
unter eins gefallenes hatten wir.
Jetzt äh seit drei Wochen äh nicht mehr, insofern kann man also von einer kleinen Trendwende reden, allerdings ist halt null Komma neun sechs noch nicht so richtig der geile
RWRt, der die äh Zahlen nach unten fallen, äh diese
aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal erfreulich. Nicht so ganz erfreulich, aber zu erwarten äh ist, dass die Zahl der Todesfälle äh weiter leicht
angestiegen ist jetzt auf tausendsechshundertzweiundneunzig in den letzten sieben Tagen und das ist natürlich schon eine ganze
Menge äh leider,
aber wie gesagt, das äh sagen das Schicksal entscheidet sich halt bei den äh Todesfällen äh in der Regel zwanzig Tage.
Vorher mit der Infektion, deswegen kann man halt sagen,
Ja, das äh die jetzt nicht weiter spektakulär ansteigen werden, sondern dass wir da
auch dann demnächst wieder einen leichten Rückgang sehen werden bei den Todesfällen, aber,
Ja, es sieht erstmal so aus, als wenn die schon noch relativ lange auf.
Dem Niveau noch bleiben dürften auf dem sie jetzt leider sind. So äh.
Das sind mal so locker zweihundertvierzig Leute, die so pro Tag sterben.
Das ist halt nicht schön ist. Vor allen Dingen natürlich vor dem Hintergrund hm dass.
Ja, die Älteren eigentlich
ziemlich weitgehend mittlerweile geimpft sein sollten vor dem Hintergrund, sind es natürlich erstmal noch
unschön hohe Zahlen, die darauf hindeuten, dass dann eben wahrscheinlich doch noch nicht so viele Leute geimpft sind.
Dir mal die Altersverteilung angeschaut bei den Todeszahlen.
Ja ja, das sind äh das sind halt vor allem immer noch achtzig plus und äh sechzig bis äh neunundsiebzig, die machen irgendwie, wenn ich fünfundneunzig Prozent der Todesfälle
aus. Ja.
Und wir haben zwar auch immer äh wir haben zwar mittlerweile auch um äh da mal jetzt dann,
zu den Inzidenzen nach Altersgruppen ähm über zu äh gehen ähm die.
Achtzig plus haben mit dreiundsechzig auf hunderttausend
die niedrigste Inzidenz und dann kommt mit vierundneunzig eben die Sechzig bis neunundsiebzig, aber das sind halt, ja, das ist halt nicht nicht zero, Covid
und ähm ja die gehen halt leicht zurück und am stärksten äh sind aber jetzt
Zahlen bei den fünf bis vierzehn Jährigen zurückgegangen, aber sind trotzdem noch äh ja von der Inzidenz die höchsten mit zweihundertdreiundvierzig,
zweihundertvierunddreißig auf hunderttausend jetzt
ja und ansonsten ja Kopf an Kopf mit den äh fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig
so die bei noch bei zweihundertneunundzwanzig pro hunderttausend liegen, aber,
Wir haben jetzt äh ja äh grade einen leichten Rückgang in allen Altersgruppen gesehen.
Das äh deutet also auch daraufhin äh ja, dass die.
Inzidenzen gerade allgemein zurückgehen und das würde ich äh sowohl auf,
mehr Wernes äh zurück äh führen,
Grund der öffentlichen Diskussion und äh Bundesnotbremse und so, das äh Plus,
natürlich äh ja die steigenden Impfquoten spielen auch eine Rolle, aber die äh spielen halt äh sicherlich nicht bei
bei den Kindern oder Jugendlichen jetzt wirklich 'ne 'ne große Rolle so das heißt da,
äh sind andere Faktoren am Werk.
Hast du irgendwie eine Meinung dazu, was jetzt genau von dieser Bundesnotbremse äh äh hier noch durchschlagen kann.
Vom Effekt her ist es ja mehr so man beschleunigt jetzt auf der Autobahn nicht mehr, man geht mal einfach vom Gas.
Also die, das ist ja mehr so eine.
Bundesfond vom, vom Gas. Geh Aktion als wirklich, dass man mal aufs Bremspedal tritt.
Ja ja ähm also teilweise äh denke ich die Ausgangssperren.
So sind halt von daher wirksam,
dass hm ja, bestimmte äh Kontakte dann einfach nicht stattfinden, dass die Leute sich dann halt Abends äh eben dann,
jetzt weniger treffen, ja. So und das dadurch, ich meine ähm,
Es ergibt ja, ich sage mal, jede Menge Maßnahmen, wenn man die alle zusammenzählt, so die Maskenpflichten. Und,
äh ja äh Abstand und ähm Home Office und äh Verbot von Veranstaltungen und
Zusammenkünften und die Gastronomie ist geschlossen und mein all das sagen, kommt halt,
so aufeinander und
Ja, äh plus natürlich Saisonalität und Impfung und äh das hat halt jetzt äh zusammen entfaltet es jetzt eine Wirkung, äh dass der R-Wert äh gerade
unter eins äh ist. So, aber leider eben ja ist es noch nicht genug.
Ein bisschen traurig, wenn man sich irgendwie so den Verlauf anschaut und und sieht so genau diese immerhin noch schwachen Maßnahmen, ja, wenn wir die im Mitte Februar einfach beibehalten hätten, anstatt äh wieder loszulabern, dann wären wir locker,
im im unteren zweistelligen Bereich,
angekommen und hätten uns diesen ganzen Ärger der letzten zwei Monate vollständig gespart und auch noch den Ärger der nächsten zwei Monate, den wir auch noch haben werden, weil.
Die ganze Geschichte ist eigentlich um vier Monate rausgezögert. Ohne Not und ohne Gewinn vor allem.
Oder? Ist doch so.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, nein, definitiv. Also, äh und ähm vielleicht später äh noch noch drauf und das Spiel geht ja schon wieder äh äh los, so mit der.
Öffnungsdebatten äh und so. Ich meine, kaum hören die kaum äh hören die Zahlen auf zu steigen schon äh ja,
Ähm.
Kann das ja alles nicht so weitergehen.
Kommen sie wieder alle aus ihren Löchern und äh ja, aber dazu äh glaube ich, später bleiben wir mal jetzt vielleicht nochmal bei den bei den Zahlen.
Was,
vielleicht noch interessant ist, wenn man sich die Pseudo R Werte anguckt, dann äh ja liegen die aktuell für die null, das Vierjährigen noch knapp äh über äh eins, aber praktisch.
Was meinst du mit Pseudo R?
Na ja, es ist so, hm, eigentlich gibt der R-Wert ja an, bei eins, dass zehn Infizierte, zehn weitere infizieren. Ähm.
Wenn ich jetzt einfach die Wachstumsraten oder.
In die Rückgänge, sagen den den die wöchentlichen Veränderungen nach Altersgruppen berechne und die dann halt.
Mit äh irgendwie hoch vier Siebtel auf äh einen R-Wert umrechne,
dann äh ist es genau genommen eben kein richtiger R-Wert, weil sich die Leute ja nicht nur innerhalb der Altersgruppen anstecken, sondern natürlich auch äh zwischen den Altersgruppen. Also,
dieser aber ich finde es halt ganz hilfreich, weil man den R-Wert mittlerweile gewohnt ist, sondern das eben auch umzurechnen auf so einen, deswegen nenne ich den Pseudo Rert äh in den,
verschiedenen Altersgruppen. Und da sieht man halt,
Ja, dass im Moment eben noch bei den Null- bis Vierjährigen die höchste Ausbreitung ist, ähm ganz knapp,
über eins und bei den ähm ja Schülern null bis äh vierzehn dann die zweithöchste noch mit null Komma neun sieben. Ja,
und am wenigsten äh also sagen die niedrigsten pseudo mit null Komma neun eins haben jetzt achtzig Plus.
Also fast, wie es eigentlich sein sollte. Aber äh eben auch bei fünfzehn bis vier bei den fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig jährigen das Partyvolk,
ja ähm.
Ausgebremst worden.
Das äh ist jetzt wahrscheinlich auch durch die Ausgangssperren ausgebremst worden und hat jetzt nur noch äh null Komma neun fünf pseudowert, aber das ist halt schon sehr.
Spekulativ, äh aber ähm.
Ja, verstehe.
Ja
Ansonsten habe ich mir auch nochmal einen äh Blick auf die Fallsterblichkeit gegönnt. Bei achtzig Plus und bei sechzig bis äh neunundsiebzig
um da zu sehen, äh inwieweit sich da jetzt die Impfstoffe,
bemerkbar machen und äh ja, da sieht man also äh deutlich, was äh.
Schon den Rückgang ab. Ähm ich würde sagen, so ab Mitte Januar bereits,
kann man sehen, dass halt bei achtzig Plus begonnen hat die Sterblichkeit leicht zu sinken und so ab Mitte Februar ging das,
dann äh los mit sechzig bis neunundsiebzig äh mit der Altersgruppe und.
Ja, ich glaube, dass korrigiert wahrscheinlich ein Stück weit äh auch äh einfach mit,
stattgefundenen Impfungen würde ich sagen. Ähm ja, dass.
Vielleicht dazu äh sagen, dann ja ein kleiner Blick eben auch auf die Tests bis zum.
Ja, das sind ja immer die wöchentlichen Testzahlen, äh diesmal die Kalenderwoche sechzehn bis zum fünfundzwanzigsten vierten, also nicht bis heute, sondern ähm bis vor fünf Tagen.
Die äh Zahlen und ja, die Zahl der Tests hat halt nochmal deutlich zugenommen.
Um ähm ja sechs Prozent werden sie in der Vorwoche auch schon mal um zehn Prozent äh zugenommen hat. Das heißt, es sind jetzt bei eins Komma vier Millionen Tests.
Dass äh ja, gut so das hatten wir in Kalenderwoche zwölf auch äh schon mal, aber ja die Testzahlen sind jedenfalls deutlich nach oben gegangen.
Und äh ja, aber die ja und die Zahl der positiven Tests ist aber.
Etwas mehr nur gestiegen äh so, aber fast fast gleich, sodass jetzt die positiven Quote nur,
um von zwölf Komma vier fünf auf zwölf Komma vier sieben Prozent angestiegen ist. Also im Grafen sieht das halt äh praktisch gleich aus, da kann man sagen, ja,
äh die die positiven Quote hm stabilisiert sich jetzt auch und das heißt.
Wir können davon ausgehen, dass tatsächlich die Ausbreitung der Infektion erstmal zum,
gekommen ist, also vermehrt sich jetzt äh nicht, aber ähm na ja, es werden aber.
Halt trotzdem jede Woche äh noch hundertsechsunddreißigtausend Menschen äh infiziert.
Das ist äh natürlich nicht gut.
Ja und zwölf Komma vier sieben Prozent ist kein gute Zahl. So, also das das muss noch deutlich äh fallen.
Ja, das ist das ist halt auch noch so ein so ein Problem, hm dass wir halt äh aktuell eine sehr hohe Dunkelziffer haben. Da gehe ich später auch nochmal.
Drauf ein, wenn wir mal die deutschen Inzidenzen und anderen Zahlen mit den Nachbarländern vergleichen.
Ja äh vielleicht auch nochmal einen Blick in die in die Bundesländer und ja äh da.
Ist vielleicht das Bemerkenswerteste einfach Schleswig-Holstein, die sowieso nur mit einer äh Inzidenz von vierundsechzig äh.
Auf hunderttausend äh Grade unterwegs sind.
Äh die nächst Besseren sind Hamburg mit hundertzwölf. Also das ist äh sagen wir schon mal in Abstand und dort geht es gerade,
auch mit am schnellsten zurück oder geht geht trotzdem auch weiter gut zurück dort. Hm.
Bei den Spitzenreitern Sachsen,
mit zweihundertachtunddreißig und Thüringen mit zweihundertdreiundzwanzig. Ja, hm, wer jetzt zwar auch Rückgänge gesehen haben.
Gestern oder heute, je nachdem aber nicht so, wie man das jetzt erwarten oder hoffen würde, weil oft hast du ja den Effekt, dass wenn irgendein Land.
Wenn's da halt sehr stark hoch geht, dass es dann hinterher auch stärker runter geht, aber die verharren halt weiter auf einem,
Niveau Sachsen-Anhalt ist auch nicht wirklich Rückgänge zu sehen. Baden-Württemberg hat sich verschlechtert.
Ja NRW, gut die letzten drei Tage, aber davor äh auch ganz schön nach oben marschiert.
Ähm Bayern äh so ist jetzt seit seit zehn Tagen äh weniger auf dem Weg nach unten.
Das ist ganz gut und ja in Berlin eiert so ein bisschen vor sich hin auf so einer mittleren hundertsiebenunddreißiger Inzidenz.
Und tummelt sich da zusammen ganz eng so mit.
Rheinland-Pfalz und Bremen und Saarland und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, die sind gerade im Moment synchronisiert.
Und ansonsten, ja, Brandenburg ist äh wieder ganz gut runtergegangen und Hamburg sieht auch ganz gut aus mit hundertvierzehn und hundert äh zwölf, also ganz gut jetzt nur.
Im Vergleich halt äh zu den anderen, aber ja, das wären halt die Bundesländer. Ähm.
Wobei man sagen muss jetzt vom vom Trend her, vom R-Wert her äh ist das Saarland grade am aktivsten, also da finden am meisten Reduktionen äh statt, die haben also,
den besten äh Ehrwert, der kann sich äh sehen lassen mit null Komma acht eins. Gut, das hält in diesen Tagen nicht immer alles, aber das sind auf jeden Fall so die Zahlen. Wenn wir die in ganz Deutschland hätten, dann äh,
wäre schon eine ganze Menge erreicht.
Ja, allerdings ist auch, äh muss man sagen, beim beim Saarland, äh die äh haben ja äh durch ihr,
vergeigtes Modellprojekt haben die ja mehr oder weniger ihre Inzidenzen da ohne Not verdoppelt. Ähm
Hätten sie das nicht gemacht so äh könnten die wahrscheinlich eher jetzt bei, bei Schleswig-Holstein äh sein. Ähm,
ja und wenn man jetzt einfach mal guckt.
Wenn das jetzt so bleiben würde, was weiß ich nicht hoffe, sondern ich hoffe der geht noch weiter runter, aber hm.
Verlassen kann man sich halt nicht drauf, aber wenn er jetzt so bleiben würde, wie er jetzt ist, nämlich bei,
null Komma neun sechs, ja dann äh.
Bräuchten wir in äh Deutschland noch äh.
Hatte ich die schönen äh Zahlen hier. Ja, ich habe ja die schönen Spaltentage bis fünfzig und Tage bis hundert, die ja beim beim,
ansteigen jetzt erstmal uninteressant waren, aber niemand jetzt wieder angucken kann, ja und es würde im Moment zweiundfünfzig Tage, also,
fast zwei Wochen dauern, äh äh zwei Monate dauern, um äh bis.
Hundert zu kommen und hundertfünfundzwanzig Tage, um bis fünfzig zu kommen. Das ist natürlich absurd. So und ich hoffe nicht, dass es dazu,
kommen äh wird und gehe eigentlich auch nicht aus, dass es dazu kommen wird, sondern dass irgendwann bald der R-Wert irgendwo,
dass wir da die null Komma acht bis null null Komma neun sehen werden, wie in anderen Ländern, wie in UK oder Israel, äh wo dann auch die Impfung
irgendwann dazu geführt hat, dass es halt.
Runtergeht. Also das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt äh nicht jetzt als Prognose sehen, sondern nur als bedingte Prognose für den Fall, wenn wenn er nicht weiter runtergeht, aber womit nicht zu rechnen, ist so. Aber umgekehrt.
Ist es so, dass wir uns jetzt nicht zurück,
lehnen können und äh weder was die absolute Inzidenz angeht, noch jetzt der Abstand, den wir zu eins haben, äh ja, lässt halt einfach gegenwärtig keinerlei Öffnungen,
Da braucht man gar nicht drüber äh zu diskutieren.
Wird auch nicht drüber diskutiert, das wird einfach beschlossen.
Ja, es ist genau. Jetzt komm, komm schon wieder natürlich, dass dass ja, das hat mich einfach auch wieder äh ja.
Dermaßen aufgeregt, dass ähm kaum, ja, kaum steigen die Zahlen nicht mehr an, äh so.
Sofort nach Lockerung äh äh geschrien, äh wieder und dann, was sich richtig auch in Farm äh fand, da läuft halt einfach entweder eine Kampagne oder die oder äh gerade die eher.
Leicht rechtslastigen Medien oder sagen wir mal Springermedien ähm.
Dass die alle irgendwie äh so eine Neidkampagne, so eine Öffnungs-Night-Kampagne,
fahren mit äh so Artikeln A, guckt mal, guckt mal in Frankreich und in Holland und in Portugal und in Spanien und in Italien, die machen,
da sitzen Leute jetzt in Cafés draußen äh so ja an dem und dem Ort und äh die haben ja.
Alle höhere Inzidenzen als wir und wir machen hier Lockdown und die sitzen schön draußen im Cafe an der Sonne, ja? So mit solchen.
Artikeln äh so, die findet man dann so, die beharrmlos äh.
Ja eingebettet teilweise in andere äh Nachrichten oder oder Meldungen und äh vor allen Dingen, was mich halt nervt, ist, dass dann suggeriert wird.
Die hätten alle höhere Inzidenzen und würden jetzt auch mal abgesehen davon, dass es sowieso sehr regional unterschiedlich ist dort, dass man das nicht nicht wirklich vergleichen kann.
Ähm sind unsere Zahlen im internationalen Vergleich.
Einfach, schlecht, so. Ähm ja, also die meisten ähm Zahlen jedenfalls.
Dazu und ähm wenn wir mal einen Blick äh auf die Nachbarländer werfen, äh dann.
Kann man natürlich klar erstmal bei die Inzidenzen vergleichen, wie das so viele Länder machen, aber äh.
Ähm man muss natürlich auch einen Blick immer auf positiven Quote, Dunkelziffer und äh Zahl der Tests und so weiter gucken und natürlich Zahl der Toten.
Auch und da ergibt sich dann halt einen Gesamtbild. Und.
Bei der positiven Rate. Sie zahlt äh einfach so aus,
ähm dass wir überhaupt, ja, dass wir die zweithöchste positiven Rate von allen Nachbarländern haben und äh nur Polen liegt gerade höher und.
So andere und einige Nachbarländer, ja wie, wie Dänemark, äh zum Beispiel, die.
Liegen, Faktor, ja.
Dreißig unter der äh positiven Quote und sogar, wenn man sogar Tschechien ähm so hat.
Einfach mal äh ja deutlich einen einen Bruchteil von dem ähm was wir jetzt haben an an positiven Quote vielleicht zwanzig Prozent oder so.
Also äh plus äh einige andere Länder wie wie Portugal,
ja, die haben richtig was geleistet. Die haben gearbeitet für ihre Lockerungen, ja? Nicht so wie wir, äh, versucht, sich durchzumogeln, sondern die haben halt richtig Lockdown äh gemacht.
Das führt dann zum Beispiel im Endeffekt dazu, äh dass wir jetzt.
Pro Kopf gemessen in Deutschland zehnmal so viel Tote haben wie Portugal.
Die ist halt richtig schlimm erwischt hatte, ja. Und da muss man nur sagen, äh ja, diese zehnmal so viel Toten äh so, die gehen ganz klar
auf das Konto von Leuten, die verhindert haben, dass hier einen vernünftigen Lockdown stattfindet, ja, da ist da ist persönliche Schuld verbunden, so sehe ich das jedenfalls. Das sind völlig, ja, also von den.
Tausendsechshundert Toten.
Sind halt tausendvierhundert ähm ja Leuten auch wie Laschet äh zum Beispiel geschuldet. Aber auch äh ja äh Journalisten
die halt,
Anfang Öffnungs äh oder Lockerungsneid äh zu schüren, so. Ja, die haben alle Blut an den Händen so für mich.
Ja. Aber äh würden das natürlich alle weit von sich weisen. Plus ganze Ministerpräsidentenrunde und so.
Bei den Nachbarländern sind wir definitiv, also Polen kommt da gerade so schnell runter, dass wir wahrscheinlich nächste Woche schon äh feststellen können, dass unsere positiven Quote äh alles übersteigt, was jetzt mit unseren Nachbarländern sich vergleichen lässt. Tschechien ist übrigens.
Bei ungefähr zehn Prozent von dem, ne.
Zehn Prozent, okay.
Also ja, das ist das Problem, ne. Also äh ich hab's ja schon ich glaube, ich habe vor zwei Monaten schon irgendwie diesen Tweet abgesetzt, den ich derzeit gefühlt jeden Tag wieder neu äh posten könnte.
Dass dass ich einfach so den Eindruck habe, dass eigentlich die Politik eben vor zwei Monaten beschlossen hat, einfach jetzt gar nichts mehr zu tun.
Ja, ne.
Nicht wirklich, ne? Also es ist sozusagen, es wird ein bisschen irgendwie was getan und natürlich gibt's auch Leute, die äh an sich Lösungen anstreben, aber so kollektiv im Gesamtergebnis, muss man sagen, funktioniert halt einfach nicht. Sondern man setzt einfach auf Impfung.
Und das wird sicherlich halt auch irgendwann äh greifen,
Ja, bloß eben werden wir gleich auch nochmal drüber sprechen, wahrscheinlich eher so in in zwei Monaten. Bis dahin vergeht noch viel Zeit. Wenn wir jetzt zweihundertvierzig Tote pro Tag haben.
Sieht das schnell aus, rechnen, dann äh gucke ich heute irgendwie in die Nachrichten rein und dann ist da irgend so ein so eine Massenpanik in Israel gewesen, dann hieß es, oh.
Äh vierundvierzig Tote bei Massenpanik, nationale Tragödie.
Ah okay, also vierundvierzig Trute ist jetzt sozusagen Leute, die so einfach so medizinisch aus dem Leben gerissen werden, ohne dass sie da jetzt Schuld dran tragen. Ähm das ist eine nationale Tragödie.
In Israel so, wenn man das ja okay, ist kleineres Land, äh kann man hochrechnen, aber man kommt in etwa so auf diese Zahl.
Und ähm wir haben halt nationale Tragödie jeden Tag.
Politik ist.
Tägliche nationale Tragödie. Gut, aber das ist äh weiter bei den Zahlen bleiben, bevor wir hier irgendwie zu sehr interpretieren ähm gehen.
Ja, vielleicht dann noch natürlich die Frage, äh wie geht's denn jetzt weiter? Hm.
Und so meine.
Einschätzung ist, äh dass die Zahlen in den nächsten vier Wochen sich.
Moderat nach unten bewegen werden mit ein paar Ausschlägen so, echt ein bisschen, mal ein bisschen langsamer, mal ein bisschen schneller, aber dass ich da erstmal in den nächsten vier Wochen.
Viel tun wird und die hm tatsächlich auf dem ich mir dann auch immer gerne angucke.
Mal sagen, ist der Großteil der Prognosen, ja kann man sagen, die Hälfte äh sagt,
steigende und die andere Hälfte sinkende Zahlen voraus, mit noch ein bisschen bisschen mehr die steigende Zahlen äh vorhersagen gerade, als die sinkende Zahlenvorhersagen, sodass es
mal die ähm der der Spread bei den ähm.
Ja Prognosen aller möglichen Institute und ähm Software, die die da gebaut äh haben,
und äh ja, also die Prognosen besagen, dass ich in den nächsten vier Wochen die Zahlen entweder halbieren oder verdoppeln werden oder irgendwas dazwischen.
Klare Ansage, würde ich sagen.
Mhm.
Es ist ja und äh ja ich äh glaube irgendwas dazwischen.
Genau, dem der Mittel der Mittelwert dieser Prognosen ist so leichter Anstieg und bei den Todesraten äh ein etwas weniger leichter Anstieg.
Ja, na gut, wollen wir dann mal schauen, wie das so mit der Medikation der Krise durch Impfung aussieht.
Ich habe ja letzte Woche mir das erste Mal die Impfzahlen genauer angeschaut und habe ein bisschen Freude dran gefunden, das auch weiterhin äh zu machen. Ich habe da jetzt keine Software für geschrieben, sondern,
das hier schön in meine Tabellenkalkulation einfließen lassen, das macht manches einfacher, das macht manches aber auch ein bisschen schwerer. Man kriegt's halt schneller visualisiert, aber man hat halt teilweise doch ganz schön viel,
Frickelei und vor allem so wie du da auch deine.
Deine Bekanntschaft gemacht hast mit dem realen Zulieferungs äh,
Quellen mit dem Datenbestand und und und wie er den sozusagen zu einem kommt. Da lief's ja jetzt bei den.
Bei den Impfungen von vornherein ein bisschen besser.
Dadurch, dass es dieses Impf-Dashboard gab und das Impftersport ist so ein Proxi, der halt die Daten, die vom RKI glaube ich im Wesentlichen
halt auch eher in Tabellenkalkulationsform bereitgestellt wird, dass das eben dann in ordentliche Textformate
überführt wird, die man sich halt runterladen kann. Nun ist es aber so, Daten sind natürlich auch immer sehr gefügig und ähm.
Man kann sie auf verschiedene Arten und Weisen darstellen und ich habe dann einfach mal geschaut, was ich halt daraus ablesen kann. Und wie schon letzte Woche hier vorgestellt, so mein primärer.
Ähm Ansatz war, ist, dass ich mir erstmal die Zahlen geglättet anschauen wollte und das habe ich jetzt auch weiterhin so gemacht.
Und vor allem interessiere mich zunächst einmal die Erstimpfung. Die Daten waren auch da und.
Seit der letzten Woche hat sich da erheblich was äh getan. Ich hatte ja gesagt, dass die,
Bis dahin so ein Drei-Phasen verlaufen sind, so eine etwas längere Anlaufphase ungefähr so bis ähm Mitte Ende
Februar
dann nahm's halt äh Fahrt auf mit äh den ersten Experimenten bei Hausärzten. Dann haben die Hausärzte angefangen zu impfen. Dann kam aber dann gleich wieder diese Astra äh Krise, dass so diese Phase zwei
wo halt die.
Bis zu na ja knapp über zweihunderttausend, zweihundertzwanzigtausend im Schnitt kam, ne, also wenn ich jetzt Zahlen nenne, meine ich immer sieben Tages Durchschnitt,
weil einzelne Tageszahlen zu feiern ist komplett pointles, also da muss man nur einmal kurz aufs
schauen, da wird ja immer die letzte Woche ange äh gezeigt, beziehungsweise man hat auch so eine Einzelübersicht über die Tage, die ist aber irgendwie vollkommen irrelevant, weil am Wochenende wird immer weniger geimpft, auch am Montag
relativ wenig äh Aktivität. Warum das bei den Impfzentren schon so war, das hat mich immer gewundert,
Die Impfzentren in dem Sinne eigentlich mehr auf so ein vierundzwanzig sieben Modus äh.
Gemacht sind, ja? Nicht alle haben auch wirklich sieben Tage die Woche offen gehabt, aber ich habe jetzt keinen zwingenden Grund gesehen,
warum aufm Montag weniger Impftermine vergeben werden als aufn Mittwoch oder aufn Donnerstag. Aber so war's. Bei den Hausärzten wiederum kann ich das verstehen,
die sind natürlich sehr viel mehr davon abhängig, bekommen dann auch ihre Lieferung eher an einem Montag, machen dann halt,
spezielle Impftage, weil die halt nicht jeden Tag impfen können, die wollen ja dann in ihrer Praxis nicht äh
normalen Patienten und die die Impfpatienten groß mischen, sondern die haben dann immer separate Aktionen, wo dann die ganze Praxis auch nichts anderes macht als impfen, weil ist ja ein Prozess, muss ja dann die Leute
annehmen, aufklären, einreihen, ihnen irgendwie einen erzählen, kurz nochmal eine Beratung geben,
sich das okay holen, alle Unterschriften, den ganzen Zettelkram, machen und dann eben den eigentlichen Impfprozess durchzuführen und nochmal die Beobachtung für fünfzehn Minuten und fällig. So und das
kann man halt einfach mit einem normalen Praxisbetrieb parallel nicht machen. Deswegen ist es klar, dass es da so eine Häufung gibt und dass die dann in.
In den Zeiträumen von von Dienstag bis Donnerstag sind es, glaube ich, auch klar. Also das hat man auf jeden Fall gesehen und ähm hat sich dann auch gleich beim
berechnen und auch jetzt beim Weiterrechnen gezeigt, dass es meiner Auffassung nach eine sehr sinnvolle Betrachtungsweise ist, diesen Wochendurchschnitt zu machen. Und ich hab's dann eben auch nochmal getrennt nach Erstimpfung und nach Zweitimpfung, weil,
uns in der aktuellen Phase eigentlich die Zweitimpfung nicht interessieren.
Ja, also wir wollen ja jetzt erstmal einen Effekt sehen und dieser Effekt wird sich primär durch die Erstimpfung einstellen.
Da äh alle Papers ja sagen, okay, Erstimpfung bei allen Impfstoffen wirkt schon extrem gut
ist das halt jetzt die wichtige Zahl. Na gut, also Phase eins war lang, Phase zwei war wellig durch die beiden Asra äh Impfstopps, dann gab's halt das erste Mal wieder stärkere Lieferungen
und äh das ergab eben dieses Plateau von ungefähr vierhundertfünfzigtausend Impfungen pro Tag
also im Schnitt, ne? Und jetzt in dieser Woche, wie auch schon angekündigt, schießen die Zahlen,
nochmal weiter nach oben und sind jetzt so auf dem Weg nach fünfhundertfünfzigtausend.
Und ich finde das relativ wichtig, dass man irgendwie auch über solche Zahlen diskutiert und nicht über diese, ja, Rekord.
Mals eine Millionen Impfdosen. Allein schon deshalb, weil ich habe, man kriegt jetzt die Daten aufm.
Immer komplett, ne, das ist so ein bisschen so wie bei deinen Daten, es gibt so jeden Tag so ein Update und dann kriegst du quasi nochmal alle Zahlen von Anfang an neu.
Und,
Ich habe jetzt noch nicht zu viel äh Aufwand da in die Analyse gestellt, weil ich jetzt auch nicht so viele Backups von den letzten Tagen hatte und das ja auch erst vor einer Woche aufgenommen habe, das Programm. Aber es zeigt sich, dass die,
Änderungen in den Daten, die nachträglichen Änderungen doch erheblich sind. Also allein jetzt von gestern.
Auf heute bin ich jetzt die,
für den gestrigen Tag neu hinzugekommenen Impfungen mal rausnehme, sondern einfach nur die Änderung in den Zahlen der Tage, die ich schon hatte, äh mit reinnehme, dann äh zeigt sich,
Dass es ähm allein über vierzigtausendachthundert äh Erstimpfungen.
Zusätzlich gab, also.
Bisher noch nicht erfasst.
Die bisher noch nicht erfasst worden sind. So und ich habe das äh habe da jetzt noch keine Heatmap gemacht oder so, aber ähm mein Eindruck ist, dass die teilweise erheblich zurückreichen.
Also Monate auch, also da wird genauso wie in den Gesundheitsämtern mit ihren Fällen, wo du manchmal auch Monate alte Fälle hast, die äh nachgetragen werden.
Ist das hier auch bei den,
Meldungen der der Impfung. Ja und ich meine so vierzigtausendachthundertzweiundvierzig Erstimpfungen, die jetzt einfach nochmal mit dazu kommen, das ist dann halt so mal null Komma null fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung.
Pro Tag. Ja.
Äh und ja, also das ist auch gut so, also das bedeutet, dass äh die Zahlen weiter äh ansteigen, auch über das, was man so täglich äh unmittelbar wahrnimmt, hinaus.
Ja. Also wir haben jetzt fünfhundertzweiundvierzigtausend.
Erstimpfung pro Tag im Schnitt erreicht und meine Erwartung ist, dass wir das ähm jetzt.
Quasi, dass es jetzt ein neues Plateau erreichen wird, so für die nächsten Wochen, vielleicht auch für den nächsten Monat. Ähm parallel dazu steigt natürlich auch immer der Bedarf an Zweitimpfungen.
Und ich hatte dann mal äh angeklopft beim Impf-Dashboard, bei dem Moritz Stefan hatte das ähm weiß nicht, ob er es alleine macht oder eine Gruppe macht, was wahrscheinlich mehrere Leute, aber der äh,
machte Daten visualisierung schon schon sehr lange, ist in dieser Szene sehr bekannte äh Person, der das impft der Sport dann so quasi,
verantwortet und der war da auch sehr responsive, hat das Problem auch gesehen, weil ich wollte halt berechnen, wie groß ist denn der Bedarf an äh an Zweitimpfungen? Das Problem ist, es hängt halt vom Impfstoff ab,
sind jetzt die Zeiträume auf zwölf Wochen. Bei Biotech sind sie halt auf sechs Wochen.
Also muss ich auch unterscheiden, aber in den Daten fehlte die Information, wie viele von den Erstimpfungen auf die einzelnen Impfstoffe
die Daten gibt es jetzt und deswegen kann ich jetzt schon etwas qualifiziertere Voraussage machen, was sind so der nominelle Bedarf ist. Natürlich sind da immer noch Faktoren drin mit.
Leute kriegen dann ihren Termin doch nochmal früher. Oder Leute nehmen ihn nicht wahr und kommen dann später,
oder Leute tauchen auch überhaupt nicht mehr auf zu einer Zweitimpfung, das weiß er halt alles nicht, ne? Das das ist dann so ein bisschen After-Defekt. Ähm trotz alledem habe ich mal so eine,
gepunktete Linie mir mit in die Grafik reingeschmissen, um so ein bisschen so ein Gefühl zu bekommen, wann denn unsere hohen Impfstoff-Lieferung,
äh äh dann wieder aufgefressen werden von den Zweitimpfungen.
Weil wir bräuchten ja dann einen zunehmenden Maße auch noch eine höhere Lieferzahl, um das auch noch mit abzudecken. Wir sind quasi angewiesen auf äh steigende Lieferzahlen.
Ja, trotzdem bin ich ähm relativ zuversichtlich, dass äh das jetzt erstmal noch so eine Weile so weitergehen kann.
Ähm würde das auch ganz gerne noch ein bisschen genauer ausrechnen, aber ich denke.
Wir haben halt jetzt so ein Level, wo so jeden Tag ungefähr null Komma sieben Prozent der Bevölkerung dazu kommt. Für die nächsten Wochen auf jeden Fall.
Falls nicht noch irgendwas Dramatisches passiert oder wieder irgendeinen Impfstoff nicht geliefert werden kann oder so, ne. Und vielleicht steigen ja auch noch die Lieferungen. Das haben wir ja auch schon öfter gesehen, gerade bei BayernTech Pfeiser. Ähm die haben eigentlich die ganze Zeit immer nur übererfüllt.
Sind wirklich fleißig äh dabei ihren Output zu erhöhen.
Würde mich jetzt gar nicht wundern, dass die angekündigten Lieferungen auch noch übertroffen werden.
Wobei wir, ja, was in so in schon Jahr eigentlich Mitte,
Mitte, Ende Mai, äh wenn ich das richtig sehe, wird der Bedarf äh an äh Zweitimpfungen äh,
oder zwei Dosen ja massiv in die Höhe gehen richtig.
Richtig, also er geht dann massiv in die Höhe, allerdings gehen auch die Lieferungen äh noch in die Höhe.
Ne, also das da die sich für Lieferungen steigen. Es hat, mir ist jetzt noch nicht gelungen, das jetzt hier in einer Grafik abzubilden, wie sich quasi angekündigte Lieferung
Verhalten dazu, also ich würde das ganz gerne noch etwas detaillierter ausarbeiten, da bin ich aber noch nicht zugekommen.
Bin aber relativ zuversichtlich, dass,
das ganz gut abgefangen äh werden kann. Aber ist schon richtig, das ist ein bisschen so die Bedrohung für die Juni-Zahlen, aber im Juni gehen dann eben auch die Lieferungen deutlich nach oben. Also wir haben.
Dass wir kurz schauen wir haben im.
Mai, wo jetzt die Nachfrage noch nicht so groß ist, haben wir.
Ungefähr so ein Liefervolumen von fünfhundert äh fünfhundertsiebzig bis fünfhundertachtzigtausend Dosen pro Tag.
Ja? Also um diese fünfhunderttausend Erstimpfungen zu halten, reicht es nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht ganz aus, aber das äh vielleicht sinkt es noch so ein bisschen.
Aber dann, wenn der Bedarf hochgeht, also ab Ende Max, so einen kleinen Überschneidungseffekt gehen, geht es dann auch hoch auf äh gut achthundertdreißig bis achthundertfünfzig, achthundertsechzigtausend Dosen pro Tag.
Also.
Und das ist jetzt so die äh Vorhersage, ne? Klar, das teilt sich dann wiederum nach den einzelnen ähm Impfstoffen auf und ne, eine Bier,
Lieferung hilft jetzt nicht, wenn jemand eigentlich eine zweite moderne Lieferung braucht, aber das scheint mir schon äh entsprechend progressiv aufgestellt zu sein, ob's dann eben auch so kommt, wird man sehen.
Also deckt sich das mit,
deinen äh Zahlen, ich habe äh hier so eine so eine Grafik äh so, nur mit Quartalsweise, Aufschlüsselung, wie viel Impfstoffe kommen und das im zweiten.
Uartal rund viermal so viele Impfstoffe kommen sollen, wie im ersten Quartal.
Und im dritten Quartal sich das nochmal ja nicht ganz verdoppelt, aber von siebenundsiebzig auf hundertsechsundzwanzig Millionen Dosen für die EU nehme ich an, äh ist das alles.
Ja und interessant ist, dass der Novi GSK irgendwie fürs vierte Quartal.
Angekündigt sind ja zwanzig.
Also ich kann das hier nochmal grob äh ich habe jetzt nur die Zahlen für Deutschland, ne, also,
ähm zweites Quartal, das was tatsächlich bisher gekommen ist und das, was angeblich kommen soll, soweit ich das habe, feststellen können, ungefähr sechzig Millionen Dosen.
Im ersten Quartal.
Einschließlich äh Dezember zwanzig haben wir neunzehn Komma sechs bekommen. Also es ist ungefähr das Dreifache im.
Im zweiten Quartal von dem, was wir davor bekommen haben.
Mhm. Okay, nee, dann müssen das auch, das müssen in Deutschland der Anteil auf Deutschland. Also ich sehe hier sagen, fürs fürs zweite Quartal siebenundsiebzig Millionen Dosen sind irgendwie.
Von was?
Insgesamt angekündigt, sechzehn Komma neun Astra, einunddreißig Komma fünf Millionen.
Bayern, Tischpfeißer, alte Bestellung irgendwie acht Komma sieben Millionen zusätzlicher Vertrag.
Zehn Millionen Johnson and Johnson.
Also das ist halt das, das, das Verwirreende, ne, also
Johnson und Johnson habe ich jetzt noch überhaupt gar keine äh Zukunftszahlen, da war jetzt irgendwie nichts zu holen beim Gesundheitsministerium, was die ja auch wieder nur in irgendwelchen komischen PDFs mit reingedruckten
Excel Tabellen, die sie von Hand erstellt haben, veröffentlichen. Gibt da keine wirklich belastbaren Daten rein und es ist auch alles extrem verwirrend, was man da jetzt eigentlich zusammenzählen muss oder nicht,
also ob's dann noch, dann haben sie noch was. Und das hier geht an die Hausärzte und das hier geht an die Impfzentren und dann so, ja, ist das jetzt die Aufteilung von dem, was kommt oder muss man das zusammenzählen oder wie? Also es gibt einfach da,
kohärente Darstellung, was jetzt eigentlich wirklich kommen soll. Es ist einfach wirklich ein bisschen schäbig und grausam. Ich habe dann eine Annahme gemacht,
aufgrund ihrer vorherigen,
Ankündigungen für Wochen, die jetzt schon vorbei sind, wo ich eben die tatsächlichen Lieferzahlen habe. Und da das dann zusammengepasst hat, ist das so meine Methode. Also nach meiner äh Methode.
Komme ich eben auf die Zahlen, die ich dir gerade genannt habe. Sechzig Millionen Dosen Impfstoffe stand jetzt im zweiten Quartal, ne? Und ein Großteil davon ist natürlich bei und Tech. Bayontech nimmt halt äh.
Mitte, Ende Mai, enorm an Fahrt auf, ne. Die gehen dann von drei Komma vier Millionen Dosen auf fünf Komma eins Millionen Dosen pro Woche.
Also sie fahren richtig großes Geschütz auf. Und ich, wie gesagt, ich wäre noch nicht mal überrascht, dass sich das noch steigern lässt. Auch bei moderner gibt's Steigerungen und Asra Sindecker, na ja, gut, ich meine, das werden wir ihnen gleich nochmal besprechen,
dünn.
Hunos, was da die tatsächlichen Lieferungen sein werden. Ist auf jeden Fall ein häufiger Pfad. Aber es ist egal, das sind jetzt alles Details. Grundsätzlich kann man sagen,
Impfstoffescoming. Wir,
kriegen offensichtlich das Hochskaliert. Ich meine, wenn wir in der Lage sind, eine Million Impfstoffe pro Tag wirklich in Deutschland wegzuimpfen über Impfzentren und Hausärzte, dann ist das ja schon mal ein gutes Signal, ja. Äh es wird nicht auf eine Million jeden Tag,
hinauslaufen. Im Schnitt äh sind wir halt derzeit etwas mehr als bei der Hälfte davon. Und das ist schon mal ganz gut und das ist auch noch steigerungsfähig.
Wir werden das weiter beobachten. Hab mir auch mal, weil es immer diese Diskussionen gibt mit Impfstoffe liegen auf Lager.
Ja, das auch nochmal angeguckt.
Ist ein bisschen schwierig zu interpretieren, weil erstens kriegt man die Lieferzahlen immer ein bisschen verspätet. Also ich habe zum Beispiel den Eindruck, dass jetzt bereits schon Dosen verimpft wurden.
Eigentlich noch gar nicht da sind. Also ich habe das,
ein bisschen gegeneinander äh geplottet. Und so stand heute, was ich quasi an Informationen bekomme, sind schon mehr Biotech-Impfdosen äh verimpft worden als offiziell geliefert worden. Aber ich glaube, das hat einfach damit zu tun, dass wir,
heute oder morgen äh äh spätestens am Montag rückwirkend dann diese Lieferzahlen äh bekommen.
Das heißt bei Bayerntech geht es glaube ich alles sehr gut raus. Und äh grundsätzlich sieht das auch bei den
anderen so aus. Ja, also das ist grad auch ein bisschen schwierig. Ich hoffe, dass ich da nochmal äh das auseinanderhalten kann nach äh Zweitimpfbedarf.
Ähm ne, weil es müssen ja auch immer noch ein paar Dosen zurückgehalten werden, weil die demnächst dann eben zweitverimpft werden und nicht immer, glaube ich, sagt man ja okay, nee, was da ist, wird jetzt auch gleich mal erst verimpft
man muss ja immer diese Balance äh halten und das ist gar nicht so einfach, da diese Logistik hinzubekommen.
Ja, letzter Punkt vielleicht noch, weil das ist mir ein bisschen, äh ist ein bisschen untergegangen. Johnson und Johnson Wagzine sind geliefert worden und sind auch schon verimpft worden.
Nicht viele, aber äh findet statt.
Das äh hat irgendwie keiner so richtig berichtet bisher. Ist auch nicht viel ähm bisher.
Also das waren jetzt irgendwie gestern war das irgendwie zweitausend, also bisher sind irgendwie grade mal so vier dreitausendneunhundert Dosen von äh Johnson, Johnson verimpft worden.
Meines Wissens wird das vor allem so für Obdachlose derzeit äh zum Einsatz gebracht.
Mhm, ich hatte da auch einen Feed.
Retweetet äh und sagen, dass in Berlin halt äh so an zwei Tagen es äh sagen, eine Anlaufstelle gab jetzt, wo sich vor allem Obdachlose melden konnten.
Ähm um dann mit Johnson und Johnson äh geimpft zu werden. So, also das hat tatsächlich auch in der Praxis wohl stattgefunden.
Denke ich auch.
Ja, so viel von der äh Impffront. Ich bleibe da dran und äh mache das jetzt auch so ähnlich wie du und habe auf Twitter immer so kleine Zusammenfassungen, wenn ich das äh gemacht habe, weil ich glaube, das
hilft allen so ein bisschen so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen und da das ja ausnahmsweise mal relativ gute Nachrichten sind, äh wirkt es dann auch.
Auch gut ins ins Volk.
Ja, kommen wir zu äh anderen Bedrohungsszenarien.
Und da müssen wir mal einen kleinen Blick nach Indien werfen, weil über Indien auch gerade viel äh berichtet wird und vor allem, dass äh auch mal wieder alles sehr medienkompatibel.
Sehr medienkompatible Horrorszenarien bringt mit den entsprechenden Bildern. Also Indien hat gerade eine Fette Covidwelle.
Wahrscheinlich einfach darauf zurückzuführen ist, dass äh die Regierung da auch so ein bisschen die Anstrengungen eingestellt hat.
Und ja, der Ausbruch trifft das Land doch extrem,
weil es eben im Gesundheitssystem nicht so gut aufgestellt ist, wie in Deutschland und gab dann halt viele Horrorstories, viele Tote, keine Kapazität in Krematorien, Leute werden da irgendwie,
Holz äh.
Schalterhaufen verbrannt, um dem ganzen Herr zu werden, weil viele auch unnötig sterben müssen, weil sie einfach nicht versorgt werden können, weil Sauerstoff fehlt, et cetera.
Dazu gibt's noch die Meldung, dass es da halt auch wieder eine neue Variante gibt und das ist ja dann so gleich wieder so.
Doppelmutante indische Doppelmutante.
Sieht man dann gleich so fünfzig Meter hoch äh auf zwei Beinen durch die durch die Straßen ziehen. Links und rechts die äh Häuser zerstörend. Dazu kann man, glaube ich, sagen,
Hobbybrauner, alles nicht so wild, ja klar, diese Variante gibt es, wird unter dem Namen B eins Punkt sechs eins sieben geführt.
Äh ja, Doppelmutante deswegen, weil es halt einfach.
Zwei Mutationen sind da im Wesentlichen anhand derer man sie so charakterisiert, also die tatsächliche Zahl von Mutation ist ja in der Regel sowieso sehr viel größer, aber es geht ja da immer primär um Änderungen in dem Spike Protein,
vor allem die, die halt in dieser äh Rezeptorbinden Domäne äh äh stattfinden, die halt.
Immer so ein bisschen Verdacht steht äh würde ich das Verhalten des Virus auf den Körper auch zu beeinflussen.
Und dementsprechend sind auch dort wieder diese Antigentests gemacht worden. Also wie das schon mit dieser Südafrika-Variante äh gemacht wurde. Habe ja auch schon mal drüber gesprochen. Sprich, man nimmt dann,
Serum von Geimpften, also Blutserum, von Geimpften, wo eben Antikörper drin rumschwimmen, setzt das dann gegen das neue Virus, was man da isoliert hat.
An und guckt halt, wie gut diese Antigne dieses Virus in den Griff kriegen. Und äh ja, da stellte sich dann halt raus, ja okay, im Vergleich zum Wildtyp.
Zweimal schlechter.
Ist aber jetzt aus zwei Gründen nicht so wild. Erstens, die Südafrika-Variante war in diesem selben Vergleich bis zu sechs Mal schlechter, also das das haben wir auch schon schlimmer gesehen. Einerseits,
andererseits und auch das haben wir, glaube ich, äh ausführlich damals erläutert und das gilt auch immer noch.
Anthygene sind halt auch nur ein Teil in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Und in gewisser Hinsicht sind die Antigener äh Entschuldigung.
Sage ich Anthygen, Antikörpertests. Ich habe die ganze Zeit Anti-Gentest gesagt.
Selbstverständlich Antikörper, ich komme auch schon total durcheinander, also nochmal Antikörper, Antikörper, die in diesem Blut von Geimpften äh entnommen wurden durch dieses Blutserum,
gegen das Virus,
Antikörper befallen dann, dieses Virus und versuchen dem sozusagen habhaft zu werden, das zu verkleben, das äh dadurch zu inaktivieren, indem dieses von außen an den Kontakt stellen,
eben über Anthygene dann ähm detektieren und verkleben. Und das funktioniert dann halt bei dieser Variante.
Halb so gut wie das beim Wildtyp ist, aber Südafrika-Variante war halt noch schlechter. Antikörper sind aber jetzt nicht alles, sondern Antikörper sind nur ein Teil der Immunreaktion.
Wichtiger noch und von diesem Experiment überhaupt nicht äh betroffen sind diese Tellen, weil die T-Zellen.
Greifen nicht das Virus als solches an, sondern T-Zellen sorgen dafür, dass von dem Virus übernommene Zellen, also die eigentlichen Produktionsfabriken, ja, diese diese Zellzombies, die eigentlich nur noch ähm,
gebraucht werden, böse Viren nach zu produzieren.
Und ja dann auch für den tatsächlichen wirklichen Ausbruch und damit auch wirklich für den Ausbruch der Krankheit verantwortlich sind. Die T-Zellen sind halt in der Lage, diese Zellen zu killen. Das sind diese Killerzellen und
die sind sehr viel wichtiger und äh,
Da geht man nach wie vor davon aus, dass die Baktine ähm genug T-Zellenreaktionen ähm hervorrufen, dass.
Dass die Krankheit immer noch erfolgreich bekämpft werden kann und das ist halt eigentlich auch das primäre und wichtige Ziel der Impfstoffe.
Krankheit verhindern. Darum geht's, ne. Wird immer viel darüber diskutiert, dass die Infektion ja nicht äh zu hundert Prozent eingedämmt wird. Ja, ist vielleicht so, aber ist auch nicht so schlimm, ne? Weil wichtig ist erstmal, dass Leute nicht krank werden.
Wir werden ohnehin irgendwann sehen, dass äh auch Leute, die.
Geimpft sind, werden sich irgendwann wieder mit SARS-CoV zwei anstecken. Ja, wir werden das alle irgendwann kriegen,
nur dadurch, dass wir schon mal geimpft wurden.
Ist einfach die Reaktion auf den Körper in einem erträglichen Maße und das wird sich dann halt in zunehmenden Maße durch diese wirkliche richtige Herdenimmunität äh abschwächen in der Reaktion, sodass wir,
ja so gedrillt sind auf dieses Virus, dass es einfach Virus ist, was uns im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes dann nicht umbringt,
Ja, trotz alledem ist es nicht schön in Indien. Ich habe da mal geguckt, wie sich das so mit Deutschland vergleichen lässt. Tatsächlich ist der Ausbruch,
grade noch so, als ich vor ein paar Tagen geguckt habe, so auf dem Level in Deutschland
Ja, also nur so für dieses Gefühl mit Indien ist ja alles viel schlimmer. Nee, wir reden nur davon, dass der Impact schlimmer ist, weil das Gesundheitssystem nicht so entgegenhalten kann. Aber hier denken wir immer noch, wäre alles super, weil ja.
Ne? Klar, das findet halt alles in den Krankenhäusern statt, auf den Intensivstationen, da werden auch viele Leute dann äh gerettet durch gute Pflege,
nicht alle, aber immerhin einige und das fällt halt nicht so auf, ne? Würde man halt jetzt äh.
Hier auch ähm würden die Leute jetzt hier auch hier so aufm Straßenpflaster äh verenden
und überall würden Scheiterhaufen brennen, ich glaub dann wäre die Stimmung in Deutschland auch etwas anders, aber die Zahlen sind halt noch vergleichbar.
Weiß nicht, ob du dir mal die Zahlen angeschaut hast im Vergleich.
Ja
Ist es noch so oder also es es steigt stark an. Ich gehe davon aus, dass das äh wenn sich da in Indien nicht irgendwas tut, sich das schon noch merklich verschlimmern wird.
Keine Ahnung, welche Maßnahmen da jetzt gerade ergriffen werden.
Ja. Ich meine, es ist natürlich auch ein äh riesiges äh Land, aber ich habe auch gehört, dass halt befürchtet wird, dass ungefähr, ja, äh jetzt äh rund eine Million.
Menschen wahrscheinlich sterben werden in dieser kommenden Welle und,
Ja, ich meine, wenn man sich, wenn man sich nur die Inzidenzen
anschaut, dann ist es in Indien jetzt gerade ganz knapp überholt, aber so Indien sagt die waren halt bisher.
Eigentlich äh ziemlich gut. Die hatten.
Im September eine eine kleine Welle äh so vor uns, aber sind dann eigentlich bis, ja, bis Mitte Februar war da eigentlich alles ganz.
Super entspannt und dann äh plötzlich ja innerhalb.
Von äh zwei Monaten ist es jetzt ich sage mal, auf unser Niveau hochgeschossen. Ähm.
Allerdings ähm ja ähm.
So ist die positiven Rate jetzt äh mittlerweile schon auf dem Doppelten, das heißt, da kann man davon ausgehen, also deutlich höher, dunkel äh Ziffer als wir, also es
halt schon mal äh nicht ganz vergleichbar dann mit der deutschen Inzidenz und ähm.
Ja, äh allerdings haben sie offiziell sagen, Pro,
eine Million Toten haben sie unser Level noch nicht erreicht aktuell, also in Deutschland sterben im Moment noch äh täglich,
an der Bevölkerung äh ja zwei Komma acht äh pro Millionen und in Indien äh äh zwei Millionen,
zwei ja zwei Komma zwei, genau Deutschland zwei Komma acht Indien zwei Komma zwei pro Million, also das.
Dass sie halt viel mehr Millionen haben.
Ja zehnmal, zehnmal zwanzig ja, fast äh weiß ich nicht, zwanzig Mal so viele, äh zwanzig mal so viele Millionen.
Wo es in Indien jetzt eigentlich gerade mit seiner Bevölkerungszahl, die sind ja dabei, China zu überholen, ne?
Noch irgendwo was, Gegend eins Komma vier oder so würde ich schätzen.
Ja, das habe ich auch im Sinne ja, eins Komma drei acht.
So groß wie Indien. Bei fast groß wie China, in China gehen die Zahlen auch zurück in Indien äh ist das nicht der Fall. Das heißt.
Das mal in Relation setzen, dann äh ist Indien siebzehn Mal so groß nach Bevölkerungszahlen in Deutschland.
Ja, also so sieht's aus in in Indien und ähm das ist natürlich nicht gut, ne. Das wird vor allem wahrscheinlich dazu führen
dass äh auch die Verfügbarkeit für von Impfstoffen für andere Länder demnächst eingeschränkt ist, weil sich Indien sehr wohl entscheiden könnte in Indien produzierte Impfstoffe auch erstmal im Land zu halten, so wie das ja
USA auch schon gezeigt haben, wie man das so machen kann. Weiß nicht ganz genau, wie weit sie da mit ihren Beschlüssen schon sind, aber das das droht auf jeden Fall.
Ja, Indien ist auch sagen Pro.
Pro hundert äh langes Indien grad erstmal bei bei zehn, elf, habe ich von ja äh ja zehn Komma acht.
Pro von hundert, also zehn Prozent äh äh Dosen pro hundert. Leute, wir sind bei vierunddreißig. Ähm nach der.
Nach. Insofern ja, plus, dass eben viele Rohstoffe und viele andere Medikamente auch äh aus Indien kommen. Und wenn die natürlich.
Größer Probleme kriegen, dann kann sich das auch auf uns.
Ja, also auf uns glaube ich weniger, aber äh auf den Rest der Welt definitiv, ne.
Nee, nee, bei äh also äh schon jetzt nicht, was Corona äh angeht, äh sondern ganz normale andere.
Normale Medikamente. Ja, das stimmt.
Normale Medikamente, äh ja, weil da halt so viel an Produktion nach Indien verlagert wurde
Wir haben ja schon seit Jahren äh haben wir sowieso schon äh immer wieder deswegen Mangel an bestimmten Medikamenten, äh die dann nicht nicht verfügbar sind und deswegen.
Ja, sollen wir mal sehen, ich meine, wenn man die die Zahlen insgesamt so sieht, dann äh korrespondieren die halt nicht ganz mit den dann wieder aufgeregten äh,
Fernseh äh und ähm Zeitungsmeldungen äh so, äh wo man denken würde, dass das Land äh gerade vor dem Untergang steht.
Das wird wahrscheinlich eben auch punktuell gerade sein in Großstädten und so und.
Dass dann es jetzt halt auch als ich jetzt den Eindruck, dass das eben teilweise vor allem den Mittelstand trifft grade, der halt völlig überrascht ist.
So das ja ist nicht nur arme Leute trifft sondern dass sagen selbst die Leute die Geld haben plötzlich.
Ja, Probleme haben im im Krankenhaus äh beatmet zu werden, so das ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen eine neue Erfahrung dort äh für viele.
Ja, dann ähm kann man aber auch nochmal auf eine andere schöne Geschichte blicken, die nicht äh so weit weg äh stattfindet von äh Indien, nämlich in Butan. Weiß nicht, hast du eine eine Vorstellung von dem Land,
Butan.
Ähm ich nehme an, dass es irgendwo äh da ja ähm.
Im Himalaya irgendwo also in irgendeinem Gebirge auf jeden Fall und bestimmt so ja so Grenzregionen, weiß nicht zwischen auch irgendwo China, Indien die Ecke da.
Würde ich sagen, ohne jetzt auf die Karte zu gucken und ansonsten, ja, also super bergig und ich glaube, so ganz, da wohnen aber nicht so viele Leute, oder?
Nee, das sind jetzt nicht so mega viele, aber immerhin so siebenhundertvierzigtausend.
Ja, also ein Saarland ungefähr.
Ist das so?
Okay. Genau, das Saarland im Himbalayer und äh,
es gibt noch eine, eine zweite Sache, die man eigentlich gemeinhin so von von Butan weiß oder die, sagen wir mal, äh so eine Information, so eine ganz grundlegende Information, die äh.
Sie haben einen König.
Ja, sie haben einen König, aber das haben ja viele andere auch.
Also das Staatsziel, so das Grundprinzip Butans ist glücklich sein.
Die sind, sie sind regelmäßig irgendwie, glaube ich, auch äh in in weltweiten Glückserhebungen, glaube ich, sind sie ganz vorne.
Genau, also es ist einfach dieses glücklichste äh Erfolg äh der Welt, ja, weil auch ihre ganze Staatspolitik so auf dieses Glücklichsein ausgerichtet ist. Das ist für die einfach wichtig. So und so so tun die dann Dinge
und ähm so machen sie das auch mit dem Impfen.
Und zwar äh waren sie das erstmal ganz glücklich, weil sie natürlich keine Impfstoffproduktion haben. Haben sie eine Spende aus Indien bekommen von äh Asra Senicarimpfstoffen?
Und äh das kam dann so in mehreren Schüben. Die haben sie dann aber nicht gleich alle verimpft,
sondern sie haben sie erstmal schön in den Kühlschrank geschoben und gewartet, bis sie genug haben, um alle in äh Butan, also alle S in.
Fast alle, äh ja, äh zu impfen, also die Erwachsenen natürlich, äh Kinder wahrscheinlich dann auch erstmal nicht. Und ähm.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist es ihn jetzt, also Sie haben dann erstmal gewartet auf einen bestimmten Tag, ja? Das ist nämlich dann der Tag des Glücks,
lag ohnehin äh gerade so vor. Was jetzt gerade gar nicht das Datum das ist, muss ich dann nochmal gucken. Auf jeden Fall äh das erschienen ihnen dann sozusagen äh ganz angemessen,
dieses Datum abzu,
warten, weil das ist dann sozusagen, das hat dann ein gutes Omen und dann dann ist das so ein, genau, siebenundzwanzigster März, ne, ist ein ein Glücksverheißendes Datum,
nach äh der buddhistischen Astrologie.
Genau und dann ist es ihnen aber auch gelungen, innerhalb von einer Woche fünfundachtzig Prozent der Erwachsenen irgendwie zu impfen und am geilsten fand ich ähm,
äh also so ein bisschen so ein so ein Risiko, was sie da eingegangen sind, weil sie haben jetzt erstmal noch keine Reserve für die Zweitimpfung, also,
hoffen, dass sie dann sozusagen auch rechtzeitig nochmal genug Impfstoffe bekommen, um dann auch die zweite äh Impfung durchführen zu können.
Und grade jetzt mit der Situation in Indien ist das halt so so eine Sache, ne. Aber äh die haben das alles ganz gut im Griff. Die Gesundheitsministerin ist auch selber Epidemologin und so weiter und ähm das geilste Argument für die Impfung war.
Der König, den sie natürlich da alle verehren, der wird erst geimpft, wenn der letzte Bürger geimpft ist.
Also wenn du möchtest, dass der König geschützt ist vor der vor der Pandemie, dann hast du dich einfach zu impfen.
Mhm. Ja, ja, ja. Ja. Mhm.
Haben auch bisher nur tausend Infektionen gehabt, es gab nur einen Toten in Butan, also von daher können sie auch ausreichend glücklich sein, weil sie sich irgendwie seit einem Jahr mehr oder weniger komplett von der Außenwelt abgeriegelt haben, ne, Quarantäne wäre reinwill, einundzwanzig Tage.
Also es trägt Maßnahmen und so weiter und äh das trägt natürlich dann auch enorm zur Glücklichkeit bei. Ja und wenn der König dann auch noch geimpft ist, dann ist irgendwie alles durch. Und er hat mich gefragt, wen könnte man in Deutschland.
Herausnehmen, der dann auch erst geimpft wird, wenn alle geimpft sind und alle würden das dann auch wollen. Haben wir so eine Person.
Habe ich, hatte ich auch äh äh sofort als als du das sagtest, habe ich darüber.
Nachgedacht und ich fürchte eher.
Dass es halt da die Leute sehr gespalten sein werden. Das ist bei manchen so, je nachdem welche Person du wählst, würden manche Leute sich allein deswegen eher nicht impfen lassen, damit der bloß nicht drankommt, ja?
Na ja, kommt drauf an, wer es ist.
Mhm.
Vielleicht gibt's ja so eine Person.
Na ja ähm.
Den den irgendwie keiner hasst.
Ja, aber ich meine, du hast dann halt die ganzen Anti-Wachser, äh.
So, das ist das die die das kann dann schon deswegen nicht.
Funktionieren, aber ähm ja ja ich.
Hätte eine Idee wahrscheinlich, wenn man irgendein süßes irgendwie Affenkind oder so, also irgendeinen, irgendein Haustier, irgendein süßes Tier, ein Panda vielleicht, genau, irgendwie,
dass die Pandas äh im Zoo werden erst geimpft, wenn äh ja, dass das sowas könnte funktion.
Oder die Katze vom Bundespräsidenten oder sowas.
Ja, ja. Ja, genau.
Stimmt. Haustiere haben viel höheren Stand als Menschen in Deutschland.
Wahrscheinlich irgendeine Haustiere würden sicherlich so, ja was was äh ja mhm.
Die Katze des Bundespräsidenten. Tja, ich weiß nicht, ob der Bundespräsident eine Katze hat, aber vielleicht sollte er sich mal eine zulegen.
Ich glaube nicht.
Gut. So viel zu Butan. Wir wünschen äh euch viel Glück. Also uns natürlich auch.
Ja, aber auch bei uns äh gibt's noch weitere äh glücks äh und Halsversprechen.
Unter anderem hat angekündigt, dass sie jetzt,
ihren Impfstoff auch für Kinder beantragen werden. Da sind wohl die Studien sehr gut verlaufen. Ich glaube, wir hatten das auch schon mal besprochen, dass das in äh Israel.
Abgehalten.
Und da hat sich das ja schon abgezeichnet und ich glaube, seitdem wir das besprochen haben, hat sich daran auch relativ wenig geändert, dass die Wirksamkeit bei hundert Prozent liegt.
Mit anderen Worten bei keinem geimpften Kind konnte in irgendeiner Form,
ähm die Krankheit festgestellt werden, was jetzt auch nicht so super.
Überraschend kommt, würde ich mal sagen, da ja nun Kinder ohnehin nicht so sehr zur Krankheit tendieren
Ähm bin mir jetzt allerdings nicht so ganz sicher, wie die Zahlen, also ob die Zahlen sozusagen auch dasselbe für Reinfektionen sagen, also äh also ob sie jetzt auch
mit PCR über getestet haben, ob die sich überhaupt angesteckt haben. Das wird man dann, glaube ich, alles sehen. Äh ich habe jetzt die Daten selber noch nicht
Gier sehen, aber das zeichnet sich ab und das würde bedeuten, dass vielleicht schon im Juni eine Zulassung,
da sein könnte für Kinder ab zwölf Jahren. Diskutiert wird jetzt irgendwie
Kinder dann ab September ähm weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, warum es dann nochmal drei Monate dauern soll. Klar, ich meine, der Impfstoff muss natürlich dann auch vorhanden sein, aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es schneller geht. Äh
ab September wiederum möchte BioTich aber dann auch die Zulassung haben für Kinder ab sechs Monaten. Da sind sie offenbar auch,
zuversichtlich, dass äh hinzubekommen, weil entsprechende Studien da gut verlaufen. In,
USA sind die Studiendaten für ab zwölf auch schon eingereicht worden und ähm ja, meines Wissens jetzt eben auch in Europa.
Das sind doch gute Nachrichten, weil ich finde grad so die Kinder.
Klar, ne. Sind nicht so gefährdet für Krankheiten, aber wir haben halt auch immer wieder diese Fälle und äh,
Ich finde auch, es ist aber halt auch für die Kinder irgendwie belastend in dieser ganzen Pandemie da äh so zum Spielball zu werden und permanent auch immer so.
Da
In dieser Angst zu schweben, so ihre ihren Eltern und wie das Virus äh in die Wohnung zu tragen und das ist auch echt kein schöner.
Also äh ja, ich meine, da gab's ja in dem Zusammenhang äh ja, ob ziemlich genau von einer,
einer Woche, äh ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das.
In der letzten Sendung besprochen hatten, äh schon diese etwas norschalanten Äußerungen von Professor äh Nieder äh Rümelin, einem Ethikrat,
Mitglied, der sich äh da.
Ziemlich, ja, also sein Lob äh kann man sagen, geäußert hat nach dem Motto äh äh ja, Kinder können wir eigentlich ignorieren äh im Zusammenhang mit.
Corona äh das spielt eh keine Rolle, die sind äh ja, äh die sind eh nicht wirklich davon betroffen, ja? So und das halt äh ja von einem von einem Ethikrat
Ratsmitglied und überhaupt war dann sagen die Frage, ja wie sieht denn jetzt das Entgame überhaupt aus bei bei Kindern, bei natürlich,
dadurch, dass wir jetzt so eine, so eine auch hochinzidenz Politik fahren
und die älteren, geimpft werden, heißt es, dass sich halt, und das sieht man
dann, dass sich die Inzidenzen immer mehr hin zu den Jüngeren verschieben, weil wir jetzt die auch sagen, die Maßnahmen nicht nach Inzidenz pro Altersgruppe, sondern halt für alle Inzidenzen
äh gelten, so wenn wir jetzt in die Situation kommen
dass da halt äh demnächst gelockert wird, weil die Inzidenzen unten sind, kann das sein, dass halt ja ja, die Inzidenzen bei den Älteren sind irgendwie bei dreißig und äh die dann aber bei Kindern äh sind dann bei dreihundert.
So und zusammen macht das dann hundert oder so. Und das ist halt so ein äh äh großes äh Problem,
und,
ja plus dann natürlich ja Vorfeld auch jüngere Familien, die sind halt auch noch nicht geimpft und ja
wenn die Kinder dann das Ganze nach Hause äh bringen und so alles alles nicht nicht gut. Plus ähm.
Ich habe mir mal äh dann ja vor einiger Zeit, das hat mir auch erwähnt, die Zahlen angeguckt, was das denn bedeutet, mit wie viel ähm,
Kindern äh wir den rechnen müssen, wenn wir das laufen lassen. Und ich bin äh so nach,
bisherigen Zahlen offene Größenordnung von ja hundert, hundertfünfzig gekommen, je nachdem. Ähm wie die Dunkelziffer äh bisher ist, wie viel bisher äh durch,
tatsächlich sich infiziert hatten, aber das kann man halt sehr genau äh äh sehen. Ähm,
ja und äh dann äh ist die ist dann die Frage ähm so also im Jahr sterben ungefähr dreieinhalbtausend Kinder äh unter,
fünfzehn Jahren so normalerweise so. Und da sind dann jetzt hundert oder hundertfünfzig äh sind dafür offensichtlich äh ja für.
Den stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden des Ethikrates jetzt nicht der Rede wert, ja? Auf der anderen Seite.
Ähm
glaube ich, ist ziemlich sicher, dass äh man bei Kindern, also es wird dann auch immer argumentiert, ja, bei Kindern, äh die sind äh auch, ich meine, die impft man ja auch nicht gegen Grippe, weil ähm ja, den, den,
passiert ja da nix und da sind dann die Impfschäden stehen, sind dann vielleicht viel höher als äh wenn äh sie wirklich erkranken, aber,
stimmt mit ziemlicher Sicherheit nicht, äh äh weil, wie gesagt, hundertfünf bis hundertfünfzig Kinder. Ich glaube, es sind in dem Alter äh reden wir irgendwie von fünfzehn, achtzehn Millionen ungefähr äh und,
ich halte es äh für, ja, äh ziemlich unwahrscheinlich, äh dass äh bei äh der Impfung von achtzehn Millionen Kindern äh jetzt
äh ich sage mal auch nur fünfzig sterben äh äh würden, ja. Also vermutlich gar niemand, ja äh und,
Insofern äh ja Plus.
Dass äh ja, dann hieß es halt ganz, ganz lange, oh ja, nee, aber wir die Kinder, ja, das dauert ja ewig, bis wir die impfen können und so und überhaupt und soll wir und aber,
ähm weil wir impfen halt auch bei anderen
Viruserkrankungen rütteln, Mumps, ähm das ist Keuchhusten und so.
Tetanus, alles Mögliche.
Ja äh wird halt ab normalerweise ab zwölf halt diese Kombinations,
Impfung, also zwölf Monaten. So ab einem Alter von zwölf Monaten so. Und von daher, ja.
So denke ich so können wir nicht jetzt also bisher hat die Politik quasi immer ohne die Kinder gedacht so nach dem Motto mit dem,
Impfangebot an jeden. Da waren halt,
offenbar die Kinder nicht mit gemeint bis September bisher, aber ja, nach allem, was wir halt jetzt wissen, äh so ähm können wir das nicht machen.
Es geht, geht nicht, äh finde ich, dass man einfach die äh die Älteren durchimpft und die,
Kinder und Jugendlichen durchseuchen lässt, zumal mir halt auch wissen, dass selbst auch bei Kindern,
die fünf bis zehn Prozent je nachdem an leiden, ja? Das ist vielleicht.
Dann äh fast noch das das größere Problem, dass äh wir dann.
Davon ausgehen können, dass äh ungefähr, wenn die alle durch infiziert werden, dass eine Million Kinder an äh Folgen leiden werden. So und das,
hat mich halt und vor dem Hintergrund äh haben mich halt diese saloppen Äußerungen von unserem äh äh Ethik äh äh Rats
Vorsitzenden oder stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden wirklich auf die Palme gebracht, ja.
Niederrhein hat sich jetzt nicht unbedingt äh besonders hervorgetan in der gesamten Debatte in letzter Zeit und äh ich freue mich halt auch, was was der da eigentlich in diesem Ethikrat soll.
Vorsitzender ist er im Übrigen. Tja. Na gut. Lass mal weitermachen,
Kleiner Hinweis findet ihr in den ein schöner Artikel über die Herstellung von des, dem Biotech Pfeiser.
Impfstoff gibt's bei der New York Times.
Die sind mal losgegangen und haben tatsächlich mal den vollständigen Prozess fotografisch,
gleitet beziehungsweise auf dieser Webseite äh sind das auch immer so kleine kurze äh Videos, relativ aufwendige Webseite
auch immer so ein bisschen das Problem New York Times, dann wollen sie ja wieder ähm gleich irgendwie eine Subscription verkaufen. Kleiner Tipp, wenn ihr euch das äh anschauen wollt, was immer gut funktioniert, ist einfach den
den Torbroser zu nehmen, davon sollte man sowieso immer eine Kopie auf dem Rechner haben. Ja, also dieser Privatsphäre äh sichernde Browser
und ähm da funktionieren auf einmal viele amerikanische News-Webseiten darum ganz gut, weil sie über Tor dann ihren Content trotzdem.
Anbieten und ohne dass man gleich ein Abo aufgeschwatzt bekommt.
Plus äh so am Ende, also bei vielen sind's halt einfach auch Cookies, äh die da äh gesetzt werden. Die haben dann oft so.
Ein, zwei, drei Dinger frei und da.
Einfach mit einem entsprechenden Cookie Manager im Browser äh sagen, einfach seine auf die Seite gehen und dann seine Cookies äh löschen und äh ja.
Dann kann es auch sein, dass man dann durchgelassen wird.
Genau. Irgendwie auf jeden Fall sehr schöne Grafiken, wenn sie denn dann laden. Ich hatte da so unterschiedliche unterschiedliche Ergebnisse damit.
So, jetzt müssen wir aber noch mal auf einen anderen Impfstoff kommen.
Ähm nehme ich Sputznick V, wie wir gelernt haben, wie das ja heißt. Sputnik V steht ja, ja, schon irgendwie so ein bisschen.
Als das große Fragezeichen bei den ganzen Impfstoffen.
Russland hatte ja sehr früh angekündigt ein Impfstoff entwickelt zu haben und den dann auch schon zugelassen zu haben im eigenen Land und angeblich auch schon wo Leute damit geimpft werden in der Armee und so weiter.
Oh, da gab's hier erst mal einen großen Aufschrei, der Wissenschaftswelt, die gesagt haben, so
alle ohne vollkommen abgeschlossene Phase drei Studie, dass hier irgendwie auf die Leute loszulassen
das ist doch alles nur Propaganda und Russland so nee, ihr seid ja nur neidisch, weil wir hier irgendwie so eine tolle Impfstoffentwicklung haben und tatsächlich ist es auch so
dass Russland ähm so als Lasserblast noch das,
der kalte Krieg so gelaufen ist, tatsächlich eine sehr starke Impfstoffentwicklungs
hat, also die Wissenschaft ist da einfach auf Impfstoffe ähm äh,
gut eingestellt, die hatten da mit Polio äh sind sie voran geschossen noch vor den Amerikanern, haben die äh diesen Impfstoff entwickelt.
Ja und jetzt wollen sie halt irgendwie Sputnik äh eV äh in die Welt bringen und da gab's ja dann auch schon so einige ähm Fragezeichen mit was ist denn eigentlich so mit Europa und Sputnik V und immer wieder klang an dass Leute so ein bisschen Zweifel haben?
Jetzt ist es so, dass das brasilianische CDC den Antrag von einstimmig abgelehnt hat.
Für die Zulassung, ja.
Für die Zulassung, genau. Ähm und das ist natürlich schon eine äh Nummer und der Grund dafür ist
dass die tatsächlich große, Zweifel haben, dass die Produktion dieses Impfstoffs in Ordnung ist,
Um das so ein bisschen zu verstehen, was da eigentlich vorgegangen ist, muss man ein bisschen ausholen. Und zwar.
Der genauso wie bedient sich ja dieser Gruppe der Adeno Viren, um,
über den A, den Baucode für das Spike Protein, Desaß zwei,
Virus in die Zellen zu bringen und die Zellen dann entsprechend zur Produktion dieses Proteins anzuhalten.
Das heißt aber auch, man hat quasi ein einen echten,
anderen Virus, von dem man natürlich jetzt nicht möchte, dass er in irgendeiner Form Unwesen treibt, im Körper. Und dazu wird dieser Virus halt,
inaktiviert. Und.
Inaktivieren heißt, dass man im wesentlichen zwei Funktionen ausschalten muss. Auf der einen Seite muss man die Funktion
die halt jetzt wirklich äh mit dem menschlichen Immunsystem interagiert, also die eigentliche virale Tätigkeit äh des Virus, die will man halt ausschalten,
Und äh wenn man eh schon dabei ist, am besten auch noch die Replikationsfähigkeit des Virus,
weil man will ja nicht mehr als das einfach die Zähne, die es eindringt, angehalten wird, Proteine zu erzeugen und.
Mehr braucht man auch nicht. Das Virus selber soll sich nicht weiter verbreiten, um da nicht Probleme zu erzeugen.
Um das jetzt äh zu erreichen, müssen bei diesen konkreten Adenovieren zwei spezifische Gene gelöscht werden, die hier mit E1 und E drei gekennzeichnet werden
eins regelt diese Replikation und I drei regelt äh diese Interaktion mit dem menschlichen Immunsystem.
Jetzt ist es aber so, dass bei den Badges, die halt ähm,
in Brasilien da untersucht wurden und ähnliches ist auch schon aus der Slowakei und anderen Ländern bekannt geworden
dass ähm wohl diese Deaktivierung dieser Replikationsfunktion, also dieses Genie eins, nicht
funktioniert hat. Das heißt.
Manche der ähm der Dosen enthalten dann wiederum adenovieren, wo eben dieses Gen E eins nicht.
Gelöscht wurde. Und es gibt da wohl verschiedene ähm
Erklärungsversuche. Eine könnte natürlich sein, dass sie das einfach im Design weggelassen haben, aber ich meine, die wissen einfach, was sie tun normalerweise und von daher äh kann man das, glaube ich, einfach mal ausschließen. Es gibt aber auch schon Berichte, die nahelegen
der Grund eben ein anderer ist, nämlich dass sich dann dass es einfach ein Qualitätsproblem der Produktion ist. Und zwar in
diesem mehrstufigen Prozess, dieser Replikation, des Virus kann es halt passieren, wenn man da was falsch macht, dass es zu so einer Rekombination kommt
Das also quasi von so einem anderen Virus. Äh dieses Gehen dann auf einmal wieder eingebaut wird.
Und im schlimmsten Fall kann diese Revolution nicht nur dafür sorgen, dass also diese Replikationsfunktion wieder zurückkommt, sondern weil ja auch dieser Raum in dem Genom
dafür verwendet wird, also freigewordener Platz wird dann sozusagen verwendet, um dieses Spike Protein zu erzeugen. Es muss ja auch diese Information noch mit rein gegeben werden, dass die dann unter Umständen überschrieben wird
Also im allerschlimmsten Fall wäre das Waxin.
Nicht nur mit einem Virus, der sich weiterhin repliziert äh äh ausgestattet, sondern unter Umständen auch komplett wirkungslos gegen SARS CoV zwei. Und das darf natürlich,
normalerweise nicht passieren.
Jetzt ist das normalerweise bei Menschen jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jetzt so ein Problem, also würde ich jetzt so ein so ein so ein Waxin gespritzt bekommen, wo,
das Adeno Virus noch publikationsfähig ist, dann würde es sich noch weiterhin replizieren ja, woraufhin das Immunsystem.
Dagegen vorgeht, wie es auch sonst gegen Adenovieren äh vorgeht, ja, also kann schon sein in den allermeisten Fällen, dass es kein Problem ist, aber man sieht da Probleme bei Leuten, die halt deren Immunsystem geschwächt ist,
Sprich Leute, die eine explizite Immunschwäche haben oder eben ältere Leute. Und deswegen will man das halt einfach nicht haben.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall gibt's da jetzt sehr viel Geschrei. Gamalia, der Hersteller und dieser äh Russian Direct Investment Fund, der so für diese ganze internationale Verbreitung des ähm,
des Impfstoffs zuständig ist, die stellen sich auf die Hinterbeine und sagen, ja, stimmt alles gar nicht, äh
Ja, es ist äh was erlaube äh die Welt und das wäre doch hier alles irgendwie politisch äh motiviert.
Aber ganz so einfach scheint es einfach nicht zu sein, ne? Weil also einerseits eben diese gelieferten Dosen offensichtlich
einfach nicht den äh Ergebnissen entsprechend, wie sie äh von den Russen im Landset äh in den Studien veröffentlicht wurden
Und ähm auch die äh IMA beklagt also äh dass diese ganzen Sicherheits- und Qualitätsdaten.
Irgendwie fishi sind. Also es haben sich Leute angeschaut und
Kritik geht so äh in die Richtung, dass halt einfach die Zahlen rein, die dort veröffentlicht wurden bei diesen Beantragungsdaten, so bestimmte wiederholende Werte rein hat bei den Antikörper nachweisen.
Einfach so nicht sein können. Also hast halt einfach,
unterschiedliche Patienten mit unterschiedlichen Dosierungen, ja, die einfach andere Voraussetzungen haben und wenn du dann eben diese Auswertungszahlenreihen anschaust, die äh die Russen dort angegeben haben, dann hast du dann immer wieder identische Werte rein.
Und ne, das ist ja so eine Probability Geschichte, ne. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen, wenn du wenn du eine gefälschte,
Buchhaltung beim Finanzamt einreichst, dann haben die auch so äh in ihrer Überprüfungssoftware so Methoden, wo sie dann, was weiß ich. Dann gucken sie an die
Häufigkeit der letzten
telle an und so was, ne? Und können daran einfach feststellen, so dass da einfach mit den Zahlen nichts irgendwas passiert ist, dass es da also irgendwelche Glätterungen gibt, irgendwelche
sich sich wiederholenden typischen Bedienungsmuster von Menschen widerspiegeln, die die Sonnig sein können, weil einfach in den Zahlen nicht genug Chaos ist.
Zu erzeugen, ist zwar möglich, ne, aber wenn man sich doof anstellt, dann wird man halt auch mal entdeckt.
Ja, also für mich war, ich habe mich dann auch immer äh natürlich erstmal gefragt, gut, in der äh momentanen, sage mal, politischen ähm Landschaft oder Stimmung oder wie auch auch immer, äh.
Man das äh bezeichnen kann, ist natürlich viel Propaganda auch äh unterwegs äh so, deswegen muss man das äh glaube ich immer mit Vorsicht genießen, ob,
und ich mich dann halt erstmal gefragt hat, OK ist es ist da vielleicht was dran dass es politisch motiviert
sein könnte, äh diesen Impfstoff irgendwie schlecht zu machen, aber.
Für mich waren dann so zwei Punkte äh Ausschlaggebend. Das eine war halt die Reaktion.
Auf diese Nachricht so, dass äh also was die dann daraufhin,
äh getwittert haben irgendwie Camelea und das ist ja Sputnik V äh äh Twitter Account äh und so,
hat dann angefangen, völlig fishi, Zahlen äh zu verbreiten über die anderen Impfstoffe und quasi die anderen Impfstoffe schlecht zu machen, irgendwie aber auf eine äh äh völlig ja.
Plumpe Art und Weise und die Zahlen, die sie da genannt haben, sind halt einfach kompletter Unsinn, ja? Also, welche Vergleiche kann man nicht anstellen, so.
Das war, sagen wir, das eine Ding, wo ich mir dachte, okay, äh wäre halt irgendwie äh wenn wenn sie,
halt äh ja seriös äh wären, also kein sozusagen ja, keine seriöse Firma oder wie auch immer, äh haut halt dann äh sowas raus. Und die zweite Sache war, was nicht nur die Brasilianer.
Auch mokiert hatten, war, dass sie, als sie die Herstellung besichtigen wollten, äh, sie nicht vorgelassen wurden, ja. Äh, das war, sagen die, die, die, die zweite Geschichte, dass sie halt einfach, äh, die Herstellung nicht,
inspizieren äh konnten und wenn ich das auch richtig verstanden habe, ähm so ich bin jetzt zwar nicht nicht vorliegen, aber es ist wohl,
so, dass es äh bestimmte Grenzwerte gibt,
wie viel Replikationsfähige Viren eigentlich in einem Impfstoff äh enthalten sein dürfen. Und.
Da gibt es wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, gibt's da drei Werte. Einmal sagen, im Westen, wenn man eigentlich gar nichts haben, also absolut minimalste Mengen, äh die.
Impfstoff Erfinder, sage ich mal, die den spezifiziert haben
den Impfstoff haben aber schon mal eine deutlich höhere Zahl,
an äh Replikationsfähigen Viren spezifiziert, so nach dem Motto, okay, wenn das jetzt unter dem Wert ist und der schieben ja immer relativ hoch zu sein, äh dann.
Ja
dann ist das angeblich okay, aber was die Brasilianern dann gefunden hatten, war, dass aber dieser Wert selbst nach dem hohen,
eigentlich toleranzwert, den die Erfinder äh dort äh vorgegeben hatten äh oder Entwickler äh des Impfstoffs, dass der aber auch nochmal massiv überschritten war. Das heißt, es ist sagen einmal
glaube ich, so ein Ding mit, na ja, äh,
wir wollen im Westen irgendwie eher weniger äh weniger Replikations fähige Kopien äh äh sehen, aber selbst ja nach russischen Maßstäben, war dann wohl in der Praxis zu viel.
Da und.
Das ist halt und auch aus meiner Sicht damit ist halt nicht zu spaßen. Ich meine, wir haben wir kennen aus der Vergangenheit genau äh also Katastrophen.
Auch äh im Impf.
Stoffbereich, die die passiert sind, dies war dann aber oft gut hier in dem Fall ist es dann zum Glück, sind es, ich sage mal mehr oder weniger harmlose Adenovieren, aber sagen.
Verunreinigte Impfstoffe oder äh nicht hinreichend deaktivierte äh Viren äh Bestandteile.
Ja, haben in der Vergangenheit schon für einfach erhebliche Katastrophe zu zu riesigen Katastrophen geführt. Also, ja, das Schlimmste.
Haben, glaube ich, mal dann in den Fünfzigern halt wohl dann zweihunderttausend Kinder in den USA mit Kinderlähmung geimpft.
Mit Kinderlähmung infiziert wurden durch die Impfung, weil die lebendimpfstoffe, weil die nicht.
Hinreichend ja genug deaktiviert waren. Wie gesagt,
ist hier also diese Gefahr droht hier nicht, aber ähm so was,
was halt ähm aber seitdem legt man zurecht großen Wert drauf, dass in den Impfstoffen auch nur das drin ist, was drin sein soll und nicht irgendwelche,
anderen äh äh Sachen, weil ich meine immerhin, ja, spritzt, wird das direkt ins Blut gespritzt oder in den, ja, äh und.
Muskel und äh ja, das ist also.
Sollte schon passen.
Sollte schon passen und äh ja ähm ich denke mal.
Das kriegen sie jetzt so auch nicht ohne weiteres mehr repariert oder zurückgeholt.
Also fürchte ich, hat sich jetzt im Westen erledigt,
aber ich bin gespannt, äh ich meine, es haben ja etliche Bundesländer, haben wir angefangen wie Verhandlungen zu führen und wollten V.
Die Bayern und äh in Wien gab's solche Diskussionen, aber ich glaube, das wird auch nicht sehr weit kommen.
In Berlin gab's auch Debatten, aber ja, ich fürchte, gut, ohne Zulassung ist sowieso nix und äh nach der Geschichte,
Ja, also die immer ist nicht glücklich und die Brasilianer sind nicht glücklich und äh ja.
Gut, am Ende äh äh des Tages ist es äh vermutlich doch besser als kein Impfstoff und zumindest haben wir jetzt nichts nicht gehört, dass dort reihenweise Leute jetzt umgefallen sind, die damit geimpft,
wurden aber nichtsdestotrotz äh äh ja, man man will da nicht äh.
Eben äh in solchen Mengen,
ähm vermehrungsfähige Viren äh drin haben, wie sie dort nicht reingehören. So, das willst du nicht und du willst vor allen Dingen, ich meine, die andere Sache ist ja
ähm auch äh das ja bei uns wird ja wirklich auch von Anzwegen äh jeder einzelne Badge auch kontrolliert,
So, das heißt, es ist nicht nur allein der Hersteller, sondern da gehen dann Prüfer wirklich in die Fabriken äh äh rein äh nochmal und gucken sich dann äh äh machen da einen Stempel auf jeden Batch äh drauf. Und wenn du jetzt,
importierten, also wenn wir jetzt Impfstoff importierst, dann wird so auch sicher gehen, dass wenn du das schon nicht selber überwachen,
kannst jeden einzelnen Badge, das dann der Start, wo der Hersteller ist, mindestens genauso einen Qualitätssicherungsprozess am, am
Staat hast und du willst nicht das irgendwie ja äh ein so und ein so und ein Wetsch so, das geht einfach nicht. Ja und äh,
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass einfach in das nicht nicht gewährleistet oder gesichert ist, dass äh ja derzeit äh dieser dieser Impfstoff.
In einer Form äh produziert und geliefert wird. Die den Westen genehmigungsfähig ist.
Und wahrscheinlich könnte man's heilen, indem dann jeder, in dem dann irgendein unabhängiges Labor, äh dann jeder einzelne äh Impfstoff äh äh nochmal unabhängig prüft,
und so, aber ja, ich sehe das nicht.
Ähnliche Probleme äh gibt's natürlich auch in Europa mit Asra Senica. Äh da wird zwar der Impfstoff benutzt, aber,
Da gibt's Probleme,
äh auch mit der Produktion, nicht in der Qualität, aber in der Quantität hatten wir schon ein paar Mal besprochen, mittlerweile eskaliert es einen Schritt weiter. Jetzt hat sich die EU-Kommission sogar äh dazu entschlossen, Astrasinika zu verklagen.
Schlicht, weil der Konzern sich nicht an die Lieferverträge gehalten hat. Das könnte noch ganz interessant werden, was dabei rauskommt. Die EU wirft halt äh Asrasinika vor, dass sie eben
ja weniger geliefert haben
Als Rasinika sieht das irgendwie so ein bisschen anders. Wird noch mal ganz interessant sein, zu sehen, wie die Gerichte das dann bewerten, was so in diesen Verträgen eigentlich tatsächlich festgehalten wurde. Äh in dem Tagesschauartikel heißt es irgendwie ja, es war ein,
für Quartal zweihundertachtzig Millionen Dosen geplant gewesen für die EU. Äh mit so Formulierungen wie nach besten Kräften,
wie Juristen.
Ja, wie, wie, wie, wie Juristen sowas äh bewerten oder Umständen? Sind da einfach so viele sprachliche Schlupflöcher drin?
Dass das alles keinen Sinn hat, aber hier geht's halt einfach da drum, Druck aufzubauen, dass in dem Moment, wo eben äh wieder Mengen kommen, die ihr dann auch zügig der EU bereitgestellt werden können
sollen.
Ähm so haben wir irgendwie äh offenbar in Quartal zwei nur ein Drittel von dem, was ursprünglich mal geplant war.
Ich meine, am Ende äh ich denke mal, in den, in den Verträgen äh äh wird schon äh sagen sowas drinstehen, wie ja,
wenn's halt nicht geht so, dann geht's halt nicht so,
aber die eigentliche Frage äh dürfte sein, ob sie nicht
äh Impfstoff zwar schon produziert haben, aber sich dann entschieden haben, äh den anderswohin,
zu liefern oder andere irgendwie mehr zu priorisieren. Das wird dann wahrscheinlich am Ende des Tages auch die die Frage sein, haben sie vielleicht äh ja.
Ähm entgegen äh vertraglicher Regelungen dann Leute priorisiert, weil Länder priorisiert, die mehr gezahlt haben oder so. So das.
Oder aus anderen Gründen. Ich meine, was der Verdacht, der unausgesprochene Verdacht im Raum ist natürlich, dass sie äh das Vereinigte Königreich bevorzugt haben, die ja sehr äh aktiv beliefert wurden.
Und selber wurde ja nichts exportiert aus Großbritannien. Äh es handelt sich halt bei Asra Sindeka um einen Zusammenschluss eines schwedischen und einem eines britischen Unternehmens. Ich will da jetzt gar keine weiteren Verschwörungstheorien,
in Raum stellen, sondern es einfach nur mal erwähnen, dass es stattgefunden hat und wir beobachten das weiter,
Ja, vielleicht noch äh eine interessante äh Studie, auf die ich aufmerksam wurde und zwar äh eine Studie aus äh dem Vereinigten Königreich. Hier wurden.
Dreihundertsiebzigtausend Leute äh beobachtet und hier ging's äh ganz einfach, um wieder die Wirksamkeit der,
gegen SARS-CoV zwei
Und ja, hier wurde so ein Saway äh gestartet, wo halt wirklich Leute auch regelmäßig einen PCR-Test unterzogen wurden. Also hier hat man einfach Leute geimpft und,
äh beziehungsweise nicht nur Leute.
Nachdem sie geimpft wurden, sondern auch bevor sie geimpft wurden, regelmäßig mit PCR-Tests ähm.
Untersucht. Ganz unabhängig von irgendwelchen Symptomen.
Und damit wollten sie vor allem die Wirksamkeit von den und ich Pfeißer äh Impfstoffen nochmal genauer aufs Korn nehmen.
Und da haben sie dann auch ganz gute Ergebnisse äh herausbekommen. Äh ich sage gleich mal ähm.
Zahlen beziehen sich sowohl auf Pfeißer, weil man generell schon mal festgestellt hat, dass die Ergebnisse weitgehend identisch waren.
Also man kann einfach mal festhalten, die beiden Impfstoffe sind einfach in ihrer Wirksamkeit absolut vergleichbar auf,
Basis der Ergebnisse dieser Studie zumindest. Nach der ersten Dosis hat sich bei,
fünfundsechzig Prozent der Impflinge einen Schutz äh eingestellt, vor PCR, positiver Infektion.
Das ist schon mal ganz beachtlich. Also zwei Drittel haben sich schon überhaupt nicht mehr auch äh nur infiziert.
Mit einer Infektion, die über einen PCR-Test nachgewiesen werden kann.
Und das ist ja schon der sensitivste äh Test. Zweiundsiebzig Prozent haben äh einen Schutz vor symptomatischer Infektion gehabt, also wo dann tatsächlich eine Infektion stattgefunden hat und woraufhin
auch äh ja, was passiert ist, irgendwelche milden Symptome aufgetreten sind oder so,
schwere Symptome und Tod wissen wir ja, gibt's äh eh nicht. Nach der zweiten Dosis, das bezieht sich aber jetzt hier nur auf Pfeiser. Ähm ist der Schutz äh auf siebzig Prozent hochgegangen,
nach PCR positiver Infektion. Ähm,
also vor positiver Infektion und neunzigprozentiger Schutz vor einer symptomatischen Infektion.
Ja, das sind ganz gute Zahlen. Dazu kommt noch, dass die Geimpften äh eine deutlich geringere Viruslast hatten. Das äh
haben wir jetzt auch schon mehrfach äh gehört und gelesen, hier ist von einer achtundachtzigprozentigen Reduktion
PCR-Test mit einem CT von äh unter dreißig die Rede, also zur Erinnerung, CT
ist quasi die Zahl der Durchläufe, die bei diesem PCR-Test gemacht wird, ne? Ein PCR-Test heißt ja, man gibt die Probe rein und dann wird immer wieder das vorhandene Material verdoppelt und verdoppelt und verdoppelt
Und wenn du nach dreißig Mal verdoppeln irgendwie immer noch nichts gefunden hast, so, dann ist da halt auch einfach nichts. Ne, also von dem, was du gesucht hast. Und ähm.
Achtundachtzig Prozent äh ist da schon eine ganz ordentliche Zahl. Das heißt, äh man kann davon ausgehen, dass einfach durch den Impfstoff einfach, selbst wenn's zu einer Infektion kommt, die Viruslast,
sehr viel geringer ist. So und damit natürlich auch die potenzielle Infektiösität,
geringeres Infektionsrisiko durch Impfung. So, aber die eigentlich erstaunliche Feststellung war,
weil sie die Leute auch vorher untersucht haben, bevor sie äh sich haben äh impfen lassen, aber eben auch in dieser Phase
wo sie schon wussten, wann sie geimpft werden würden
ja? Haben sie festgestellt, dass drei Wochen vor der Impfung schon das Infektionsrisiko bei den Leuten um zweiundsiebzig Prozent sank.
Wenn sie nur wussten, dass sie einen Impftermin haben.
Also so eine Art Endspurt Effekt, so dass Leute so, oh, jetzt weiß ich in drei Wochen werde ich geimpft oder in was weiß ich, vier Wochen äh ist mein Impftermin, dass sie sich dann einfach,
automatisch anders verhalten, so nach dem Motto, jetzt weiß ich irgendwie, ich werde bald befreit, jetzt will ich's auch nicht versauen.
Auf den letzten Metern will ich mir jetzt nicht noch äh äh irgendwie so eine so ein Covid eintreten, ja.
Genau, so. Und das heißt, man kann eigentlich festhalten, Impftermine helfen gegen Corona.
Ja
Also man müsste eigentlich den Leuten nur einen Impftermin geben und schon äh würdest du die Infektionsrisiko um zweiundsiebzig Prozent senken.
Ja, ja, vielleicht ist das ja auch der Effekt. Ich meine, vorhin äh sozusagen äh.
Ähm wenn man das scheint offensichtlich ein realer Effekt zu sein, äh dass äh jetzt äh ja die Impfterminvergaben.
Sagen du allein durch das Anziehen der Impftermin vergaben jetzt und äh sagen auch der Meldung, ja äh überhaupt, dass jetzt mehr Impfstoff kommt, wir vielleicht tatsächlich auch so einen Endspurt
Effekt äh sehen, dass viele Leute jetzt besser aufpassen, weil sie erwarten, äh dass jetzt die Impfung bald
kommt. Das äh natürlich eine interessante Hypothese äh für die einiges spricht. Ja.
Genau. Also ich kann mir das wirklich sehr gut vorstellen, ne. So dieses wie wie doof stehst du da.
Wenn du schon das Ziel vor Augen hast und es einfach auf einmal so konkret fassbar wird und deine,
Lebensplanung in gewisser Hinsicht so eine Art Ziel bekommt, weil ich glaube, was viele Leute auch so ein bisschen madig macht und auch ein bisschen nachlässig macht, ist so diese gefühlte Unendlichkeit dieses Problems. So dieses oh
ne und so wie man sich auf so wie man sich schon gut fühlt, wenn man weiß, dass man in sechs Monaten Urlaub macht.
Dass man eigentlich auch die Zeit davor, sich schon besser fühlt, weil man sich die ganze Zeit drauf freuen kann,
So einen ähnlichen Effekt hast du hier offensichtlich auch in in deinem Sicherheitsverhalten, dass du sagst, okay, ich will mir doch jetzt nicht diesen schönen Moment,
der Freiheit.
Ausgerechnet jetzt dadurch verkacken, dass ich jetzt irgendwie einen dummen Fehler mache, während man ansonsten über sowas überhaupt nicht nachdenkt.
Nach Alter aufgeschlüsselt hatten die das nicht oder?
Tja, keine Ahnung. Ähm müsste ich nochmal reinschauen in die äh Studie, ob da was zu finden ist.
Ich sehe auch nichts nach Hahne, nach Altersgruppe.
Aufgeschlüsselt, sondern eher nach äh sagen, wie lange äh nach der Impfung und so, weil hm.
Das ist natürlich so ein so ein Ding äh so diese neunzig Prozent sind dann halt über alle Altersgruppen äh hinweg.
Und äh ich bin ja neulich äh auf das Problem so ein bisschen gestoßen, dass äh.
Eben äh ja einfach bei älteren, teilweise äh die Impfstoffe einfach äh nicht so gut äh wirken.
Oder schlechter wirken. Das heißt, äh ich meine, da ist zwar immer noch viel Schutz äh dabei, aber es gab halt eben bei über Achtzigjährigen irgendwie bei einer Studie.
Gesehen habe, halt dreißig Prozent, die keine äh äh messbaren, neutralisierenden Antikörper entwickelt, äh haben nach der Impfung.
Und die gehen dann zwar weg nach einer gewissen Zeit, aber bei denen konnte also gar nichts. Null,
festgestellt werden, ja. Was jetzt nicht heißt, dass sie irgendwie auch gar nicht geschützt äh äh wären, aber,
so ich hab das Gefühl das wird im Moment zu wenig im Zusammenhang mit der Impfung da zu wenig drauf geguckt und.
Ähm weil ich mich eben immer frage äh und nicht nur ich, äh sondern wir haben ja jetzt achtzig Plus eigentlich schon komplett durchgeimpft so, wo kommen die ganzen Infektionen her und wieso sterben.
Da immer noch Leute, ja? In solchen Mengen, so, dass es es halt immer so ein bisschen das, das Rätsel.
Gerade und.
Weil wir aber auch nicht die Impfquoten kennen und so und nicht wissen, äh auch wie jetzt genau wie wie hoch der der Anteil jetzt der, ja, Impfversager oder Non-Responder.
Ist äh äh in den, in den verschiedenen Alters äh Gruppen äh ja äh sehe ich da also noch so gewissen äh ja.
Äh Forschungsbedarf äh beziehungsweise bedarf halt äh auch ähm.
Ja, war eigentlich die wieder die Inzidenzen niedrig zu halten so, weil äh.
Das Gefühl habe, dass viele Leute glauben, naja jetzt, wenn die alle durchgeimpft sind, ist das alles überhaupt kein Problem mehr. Aber äh noch noch ist es definitiv nicht der Fall und äh ja,
aber das ist zum Glück halt auch die meisten äh älteren Leute tatsächlich.
Ähm vor dem Tod schützt, aber ähm ja,
wir hatten dann eben diese auch noch nicht aufgeklärten Fälle wo sich dann ein Drittel der Leute im Altersheim infiziert hatten obwohl fast alle geimpft waren und durchgeimpft waren und so und das,
Also solche Sachen, ja, weiß ich nicht, finde ich, beunruhigend.
Unterm Strich wissen wir, wenn die, ich sage mal, wenn wir die fünfzig Prozent irgendwie überschreiten, haben wir aus Israel gesehen an.
An Impf äh Quote, dann geht halt einfach auch generell äh der Virus weg äh äh so, wobei ich auch schon.
Ja äh jetzt Simulation äh gesehen habe, die halt auch dann im Herbst äh.
Gewisse neue Wellen hervor äh äh vorhersagen, die zwar nicht groß ausfallen werden, aber so all das äh ja,
Äh ist jetzt noch ein bisschen unklar. Wir werden sehen. Wir haben ja zum Glück, wie gesagt, Israel und andere Länder, wo wir.
Wie sich das wie sich das entwickelt.
Und Pavel, das ist unser letztes Thema. Jetzt nicht wieder äh in irgendwelche Dysopien äh abgleiten, ja? Das ist so die positive Botschaft zum Schluss ist, Impftermine äh helfen gegen Corona und das ist schon mal ein guter Grund, sich auf sein demnächst anstehenden.
Termin zu freuen, ja? Damit ihr alle schön positiv seid. Und demnächst gibt's halt auch mehr,
ne. Gibt immer wieder anekdotische Evidenz von Leuten, die sagen, ja, mein Termin ist aber erst im Juni und ich bin ja in Gruppe sowieso meine Erwartung ist, wir werden jetzt im.
Mai.
Eine ganze Menge Termine sehen, die vorgezogen werden. So, das heißt, äh vielleicht habt ihr sogar die Gelegenheit, äh früher dran zu kommen oder so, auf keinen Fall später, als ihr jetzt vielleicht schon einen Termin habt und ähm.
Dann wird sich, dann wird sich das alles ganz schnell wieder aussortieren. Alles wird gut.
Zum Fazit kommen. Oder zum Ausblick.
Zum Ausblick, also.
Ausblick äh ist, äh dass wir jetzt äh gerade mal wieder eine Chance haben, die Zahlen nach unten zu bringen und äh sie auch nicht wieder steigen äh zu.
Lassen, äh ob für sie ergreifen äh äh werden oder ob äh,
dann äh jetzt in den nächsten Wochen äh dann,
ja äh die Öffnung und äh vor allen Dingen ja mhm dass die die die Vorsicht wieder nachlässt äh und sich die.
Die Entwicklung umkehrt, wollen wir jetzt nicht hoffen, aber die Gefahr äh besteht. So, also es ist nicht so, dass dass die Pandemie jetzt gelaufen ist und dass wir uns entspannt zurücklehnen und auf den Impftermin warten können, sondern wir müssen halt auch noch ein bisschen,
äh was tun. Ja, damit die Zahlen runtergehen, aber es besteht Hoffnung. So, im Moment würde ich sagen.
Leute, das war's, euer Corona-Wickli für diese Woche und nächste Woche gibt's ein neues, Dienstag könnt ihr auch gerne wieder mit uns diskutieren auf Clubhaus und.
Wir wünschen euch eine schöne Restwoche und bleibt gesund und äh.
Ja, dem schließe ich mich an. Macht's gut. Bis demnächst.
Ciao.